we were just conferring and um taking
notes of the representatives uh that
said they couldn't be here today so I
think we have
we have more than a quorum and we will
begin
and I understand uh represent Faulkner
is not feeling well today so if you're
watching uh best to you
so we will start with the commandant for
the veterans home
um and please come forward and it's a
sincere pleasure to have you back here
and uh welcome to Public Works
good morning for the record my name is
Kimberly McKay I'm the commandant of the
New Hampshire veterans home and today
with me I have
Brian Baker at supervisor of Safety and
Security and acting supervisor of
Maintenance at the veterans home thank
you
foreign
so I have a handout here a PowerPoint
handout uh just goes through the history
of the New Hampshire veterans home at
the beginning
um that we've been around since 1890.
um we are 250 bed licensed facility
long-term care not skilled we are
budgeted for 225 and our current census
today is 129 veterans
um 118 men and 11 women
are our average age for our veteran is
83 years old and their average stay is
three years
currently our census is that count
because of our staffing we have
challenges with Staffing as I'm sure
everybody has been experiencing and so
we feel that we can safely meet the
needs of the veterans at 131 veterans so
that's where we're Staffing or have
having the census go to but the goal is
with a lot of our
recruitment efforts is to go up to that
225 we feel that we can fill those beds
and meet the needs of the veterans in
the community
our mission is to provide the veterans
with the best quality of life with
dignity honor and respect
so our strategic infrastructure
priorities has really been about health
and life safety and to meet the VA
requirements we are surveyed by the VA
once a year and they are the ones who
give us our per diem rates for our
programs and so we need to meet the
needs of their survey requirements as
well so our current projects are the
building-wide sprinkler system upgrade
that was something that wasn't put
through the regular budget process it
was actually added last year because we
had a VA survey when they came through
they did their inspection and one of our
sightings was that we didn't have
sprinklers in our closets
we had never had sprinklers in our
closets and we challenged that
deficiency
with the New Hampshire
information that we had but they still
said no federally we had to have them so
that has been added to our current
projects and we're underway with that
project
we also have an existing parking lot
repair and Expansion Project that we're
hoping will be done this summer we're
underway with that and if you want more
details Brian could provide those
timelines
the other one that is still on the books
with us is the Life Enhancement dementia
unit third floor Edition
I'm often asked why we're asked asking
for an addition when we don't have the
beds filled right now and that's because
during the pandemic it became even more
clear that we have to provide rooms to
Residents in a different manner our some
of our facility is an older facility and
it's two rooms with shared bathrooms uh
two people in each room and we know that
from a covered perspective or even any
kind of flu with any kind of congregate
living having them live so closely
together it can spread quickly so the
goal of the addition is to provide
smaller living housing with private
rooms and private bathrooms not to
increase our numbers but to provide a
better use of our facility and provide a
better safe environment for our veterans
and then the third the fourth one is a
medical lift installation uh we are
moving to providing uh putting in
bariatric lifts in the ceiling uh
instead of having Hoyer lifts that
traditionally we bring in the room and
we help lift a resident uh two reasons
for that is one they're uh they have
weight limits that we are seeing people
exceed uh and two that there is a risk
of injury both to the veteran and to the
staff that are helping so these are much
safer right now we're putting an 11 from
the last budget that's what this money
is for from the current project but we
have to make a decision when we look at
admissions where we put certain people
that need these our goal is to have them
in all the rooms eventually so I will
continue asking for
um a few here like 11 each year until we
get up to that number because the
numbers is large and so we're trying to
get those lifts put in the facility
the three projects that were carried
forward on the governor's budget were
the site-wide drainage and water life
safety improvements
the entry Life Safety Improvement
entryway Life Safety Improvement and the
medical lift installation phase two
um I I like to include photos because I
think that I can tell you what's going
on but it's much easier for you to see
them and at this point I'd also like to
offer you if you would like to come in
for a tour of our facility we will show
you uh all the things we're talking
about all these are like the ugly parts
of the facility but I'll show you the
great Parts too with the residents but
this is the this is the water that's
coming up uh water drainage issues if
it's raining if we have snow melt off
pretty much anytime there's water that's
coming down out of the sky it's going to
come in our basement
we can see here this is water coming
right out of our datapore after a
rainstorm
this is the floor that is near our
emergency generator that it just comes
in and we've have to we have to vacuum
that out and mop it out
on the next page you'll see this is our
electrical panel and you can see the
watermark stains that have come in
again the same room and then we have the
dehumidifier that is working really hard
but this is a it's really corroding our
entryways our flooring on the next pay
the page that has it looks like a window
this is actually a entryway that goes
from our dining room into a hall which
residents use every day
um many times a day this is eroding the
floor so the tiles are popping up
they're cracking and this is actually uh
I think Brian could speak better to this
what the second one is a Footers
yeah so the water is coming in basically
coming in along the footings and weeping
up through the floor so this is kind of
a small area that you're looking at here
but there's uh I mean I could have gone
taken pictures every 10 feet and you
would have seen where the water is
pushing up through the floor and it's
kind of popping the tiles up
foreign
entryway Life Safety improvements this
is where we're asking to for funds to
construct four entryway canopies we
don't have any canopies over these areas
and we're showing you pictures of this
right now
um this first picture of the snow coming
off the roof this is a temporary canopy
that the maintenance department has put
up
um very temporary but because that is a
main entrance we have two main entrances
our staff come through we are worried
about the safety of them coming through
this is also
um an entrance where residents will
often come out as well and so you'll see
the snow overhang on all of these areas
where it comes off we have to close down
a sidewalk every year in the front of
our building because the snow falls off
and we're just worried about the safety
of somebody getting hurt there so we're
asking for the entryway Life Safety
improvements to build those canopies
the medical lift installation is a
project that is outfitting the building
with ceiling lifts as I said this is an
example of what one looks like
um and it can it can lift 650 pounds
um up to 650 and so we're really trying
to have those in place so that we can
prevent injury and uh to both the
resident and the staff
and then I was asked to talk about the
lapse date extension budget and so uh
the
firewall the Ladue firewall project has
been completed
the Ladue building is the project that
is at the VA right now that's the third
four building so we're waiting for the
VA the way the Veterans Administration
is is they get all of the requests from
all of the different state veterans
homes in the United States they put them
on the project list and then they choose
which projects each year so we're in
that process where they haven't chosen
us yet but that's one of the things that
we're waiting for is word from the VA
and then the parking lot as I spoke it's
due to be done this fall
um we're hoping sooner than later
because the parking lot right now is
very unsafe our sidewalks are unsafe so
we're hoping to see that happen sooner
than later
thank you uh questions from the
committee yes
representative Jack thank you Mr
chairman it's good to see you again uh
just to confirm we're going to lapse
item 223
on page 19 and that is a lapse of 1.293
million
are we going to yes I would like to
continue us so we're going to delete
that from hb25 I have one more question
uh about on the
slide that has the building wide
sprinkler system and the medical lift
phase one it wasn't clear to me uh how
that was funded and what authorized it
we went to fiscal committee and GNC and
um
actual operations
operations
okay thank you you're welcome
further questions
yes representative Boyd thank you Mr
chairman comment on thank you for your
testimony thank you how many bariatric
lifts need to be installed
we have 11 that we're putting I know 11
come in but all together what's the
what's the long term
um I I think that if we could have 40 to
50 honestly like a middle middle of the
road for our staff uh for our rooms we
would be able to place people better so
50 would be the total I think that week
big deal yes okay follow-up Mr chairman
yes just a dovetail offer representative
Jack's question I I didn't think it was
clear and I apologize regarding the
lapsing
you are we are lapsing 1.293 million
dollars that is correct yes I'm sorry
I'm looking at Stephanie Kelly that's
okay no that's fine yes yes in layman's
terms you're giving it back to us
yes she's saying yes thank you
I I uh I have an obvious question
perhaps you can answer and perhaps
there's only one model
the um on the lifts and we're doing the
same thing in in our County nursing home
uh for staff and for the convenience of
the resident
um is 650 pounds where it starts is
there a 500 pound 400 pound model I
think that they go to the 650 as a
standard most of the equipment is now
going to 650 So when you buy a bariatric
lift it's 650 if you buy a bariatric bed
it's 650. okay thank you for that
welcome now yes representative
Magic
I just have a simple question
how many veterans are in
your care at this facility 129 today we
have 100 129 veterans in our facility
today
any further questions
yes represent Beloit
um just to explain so what are you going
to do to address that drainage it looked
pretty severe all that water going into
the basement so what's the plan for that
I'm just it doesn't seem like you're
spending that much money to do this so
what's the plan well our hope is that
somebody can come and do a design and
tell us how to fix it and we're hoping
that for the 350 we'll be able to find a
fix for that originally we thought that
it would be about 540
um thousand but uh we're hoping with
this we can do a site-wide assessment
drainage design and a fix
we're hoping it's gonna not gonna be too
difficult
so to answer your question
yes
um pretty good price
just out of curiosity on these lists
they will lift up to 650 pounds
they're attached via into the ceilings
yes and does the ceiling because I know
square footage poundage per square foot
is sometimes an issue and especially in
older buildings is the building capable
of
safely handling
that requirement yeah so they before we
purchase these lifts and look to
purchasing these lifts they did have to
come out and do an assessment to make
sure that it could handle that weight
so it has been looked at
yes
uh representative Newman the building's
adjustable yes thank you
for clarification when you said the
firewall
has been
replaced whatever
going back maybe the previous or maybe
before that capital budget
I remember a picture that showed the
um the the wooden frame ups and there
just wasn't any of Separation that
should have been done at time of
construction yeah yes that is correct so
in 2003 when the building was built
it was designed at the time for the fire
codes at that time and then the fire
codes change over time and same with the
sprinkler upgrades we have to upgrade
our building as the codes change
thank you
thank you any further questions
we will put you on our list of site
visits I I have never been there and I
would uh truly love to come by see the
facility and the folks so excellent
we'll look forward to it okay thank you
that'll conclude our meeting with the
veterans home and we will continue at 11
o'clock with the Department of
Corrections
so for the committee we're we're running
through all of the um all the different
parts of our state government
Commissioners and so forth when we
conclude with this next Wednesday
we actually open up and have a public
hearing on House Bill 25 and if there
are people outside or if others want to
come back in these departments to speak
to us one more time
that's the purpose of that meeting on
that day and then we will start going
through I think we've mentioned this
we'll start going through and and find
which items we can all agree on and
start through the process hopefully by
the 20th we're going to be to a point
that we can reach agreement make
amendments to House Bill 25 and then be
able to move forward so if you have
questions to me please come by otherwise
we're
we are free till 11 o'clock
the uh time being 11 o'clock we will
Public Works and highways will move on
to Department of Corrections and
commissioner Hanks welcome please come
forward with whomever you would like
with you
and present your capital budget and once
again welcome to Public Works
red no it's red good red is good okay
good morning uh for the record uh Helen
Hanks commissioner of the Department of
Corrections and to my right is John
Hansen our director of administration I
thank you honorable members of the
committee for the opportunity to present
our capital budget to you today
I skipped the first page that's not a
good start
page one in the governor's proposed
capital budget you'll see we have two
items our radio system upgrade and
rebuilding the sewer line and grinder at
the New Hampshire state prison for men
the radio system upgrade is a project
we've been tracking and trending for
some time we still have analog system
and we need to move to a digital system
and that's our primary tool for Safety
and Security at all of our Correctional
locations if there's one tool a
corrections officer cannot go without it
is their radio and even the other
infrastructure that sends the
information to the radios is aged and it
is time to get this moving forward in
the proper direction and a replacement
in process the second project is a
project that was previously approved and
this is unless John corrects me
otherwise an additional appropriation
because the original funding was is no
longer in scope for the total cost of
the project and I'll look to John to
speak in depth on that project
so this is the one and uh sorry John
Hanson for the record director
administration department of corrections
um it's good to see a lot of the same
faces here so you know what I'm going to
be talking about uh this was the muffin
monster the sewer grinder which was put
in the street and Maguire Street the
city of Concord asked us to move it out
appropriately that was installed in 1994
right off the curb line but when they
went in to look at the design of how to
replace the muffin monster as well as
the sewer line going to it the cost has
escalated and it will require us to put
a building in because in this case we'll
now have an auger so a lot of the things
that don't make it through the grinder
will be picked up in auger and actually
brought out and put into the trash so
that's why the request for the
additional money there
all right I just wanted to comment on
page two and three of the next slides
talk specifically about those two
projects number two showing our Radio
Room at our New Hampshire state prison
for men and referring back to the new
equipment needs to meet both state and
federal standards and obviously why
we're proceeding with that request and
slide number three yes is a lovely
picture of the muscle muffin monster on
South Street
if we uh have you go to page four we
we've included which is unusual for us
this year
um hb2 items associated with a long
standing conversation around the
infrastructure at the Hampshire state
prison for men
and trying to find a solution within our
state process on funding such a large
and significant project so in doing so
the governor included a non-lapsing
appropriation fund for the design and
construction of a new New Hampshire
state prison for men it is our largest
facility here in Concord and houses
today approximately 1200 men and has
held upwards of 1600 men in the past
in addition to we've included for your
Vantage Point an hb2 item associated
with our computers and infrastructure as
well
do you wanna
thank you commissioner um and we follow
up on the following Pages if you have
the old form 1A which I believe uh you
have in front of you which is our
initial submission of what we submitted
we have our top seven there on that page
and as you'll see on page five
um highlighted on the left hand side is
items one and two which made the
governors recommended but there were
other items on there item number one was
our first request and this was actually
tailored down to a 2.5 million dollar
study to determine whether or not we
could put the prison where we think we
could put it and determine what the size
would be and that has now been changed
into what's in House Bill 2 which is a
50 million dollar uh budget for that to
start construction and item number two
the kitchen renovation that's the money
that we already have appropriated we
have 4.3 million dollars and that
project is in design and moving forward
but to actually complete that as we
started to get into the to the meat of
that building determined we had pipes
collapse beyond what we what we felt we
had we've been working with Public
Health on some of the things that needed
to be changed it'll come up in the
slides a little bit later on and
actually Public Works and the
engineering firm that they hired up that
to another 7.1 million dollars to
complete that project and I bring those
up just knowing that if we do move
forward with a 50 million dollar new
prison we will not need that additional
money because we can use the 4.3 million
dollars what's left of that unless the
architecture and engineering fee to keep
that sustainable and keep it so that
it's in compliance with the public
health regulations
um item number four let's get Buy number
three of course that's that radio system
upgrade the commissioner talked about is
the steam lines and traps again going in
and looking at Price escalations which
we've seen and I don't know whether
you've been following the news but just
since January of 2023 construction cost
ex escalations up 12 in just the last
three months steel cost went up 100
percent in the last three months
according to the to the statistics the
state of national statistics lumber
prices are up 90 percent glasses up 30
percent and the list goes on and on so
these price increases this is kind of a
theme as we go along here as we started
to get into that project we needed more
money
um to complete item number six the
perimeter and fence detection systems at
the New Hampshire prison for men need
another million dollars we determined
that there's too much work needed to be
done with steel and concrete allowing
the exterior perimeter walls to make
that again to keep that safe and secure
in both directions people coming in are
trying to get out
um item number seven is the construction
trades building at the women's facility
which is some of you folks that were
around during the time we built that
there was actually room set aside for
that which has now become a canteen uh
so we need to build an outer building
for the construction trades
and then following on page six of the
remaining items that were in your
original form 1A and I just go down
through these so that you can see the
ones for ncf and the other facilities
obviously we'll still need but if we get
the money on the house bill too many of
these things will not be need to be
completed however one caveat the
commissioner I talk about quite quite
often is that it will take time to build
a new Men's prison that current Men's
prison needs to be completely functional
safe secure throughout that complete
duration until we actually move those
residents to the new facility and right
now what we're dealing with is the the
incarceration of those residents that's
the punishment the building and the
architecture shouldn't be and that's
what we're dealing with today because of
the amount of repairs and things we have
and if I could the importance of the New
Hampshire state prison for men's
infrastructure is not just because it is
a Correctional Institution for people
who have committed felonies but the
infrastructure is equally if not more
important for the individuals who work
in there 24 hours a day seven days a
week when I walk into a unit after the
my 20th year with this organization and
I started in our reception and
diagnostic unit at the New Hampshire
state prison for men and when I went in
there last week and I appreciate the
members of the legislature have been
through the facility and those that have
yet been able to do that we certainly
offer that opportunity and see tarps
with hoses dripping into buckets right
where my officers are working it
continues to frustrate me that we're
working in a infrastructure that is as
old as 1878 and we really need the
legislature support in trying to rectify
the situation
thank you commissioner continuing on
that page if you had any questions I can
get into the meat in more detail
granular detail on any of those ones
that are on that item on the page okay
why don't we pause for a moment and talk
about what's what's previously been
discussed repjam Jack did you have
something well uh thank you uh I would
could we speculate on whether the new
prison would go on the same site or or a
distant site
yes um so what we've been working along
with public works and with some others
and the City of Concord Deeds which
we're looking at adjacent to our
property there is 383 Acres on the side
of the road that the women's prison is
on in the Men's prison is on now the
land up back is an Old Quarry there are
many places where there's ledge
outcroppings and as we did with the
women's uh we plan would be to to scope
that land out and potentially do what we
did at the women's facility which you're
familiar with we crushed that granite
and we used that for the product on site
eliminating all trucking on North State
Street which the city and the abutters
were very concerned with except for a
few minor loads of gravel that came in
later on so that would be the site up
back we have a lot of work to do to make
sure it's it's feasible but if it's
where we think it will be it will be far
enough out of sight of Mind from all the
residents in that area it's going to be
buttered by the Cavalry cemetery on one
side in Long Pond or Penacook Lake on
the other side
thank you follow-up uh thank you one of
the things that mitigated to putting the
women's prison where it is was sharing
the infrastructure and utilities and so
forth is that still going to be a
consideration with with that site yes
exactly and as as we work through this
the commissioner and I looked at that
site with all the utilities that we have
there we have the 60 inch high pressure
gas main That's Unique for the city of
Concord we have the highest power that
you can get off that power line which
comes the same one in the trunk with
Concord Hospital we have the water which
is again it's adjacent to the to the
reservoir the City Reservoir there may
be some pumps and things needed but yes
utilities are there
thank you further questions
yes representative valois thank you Mr
chairman the loan I'm sorry so I want to
talk about Staffing and the facilities
um I know that you are severely
understaffed
um
so are you taking that into
consideration for your design for the
new facility so that it minimized so
actually you can kind of get by with
fewer staff because I I think everyone's
working overtime now pretty much
uh thank you for that question yes the
staffing has been a challenge and uh
significantly exacerbated post covet we
had a lot of individuals deservedly
retire after those uh grueling years and
the current campus it literally the fact
that I call it a campus is already
Staffing inefficient and so just as we
learned our lessons as we built the
women's facility and even our experience
in 2000 with the northern Correctional
Facility this facility would be built
focusing on how do we staff this safely
but efficiently and incorporating
technologies that best assist in a
correctional institution thank you for
that question
in in the let's discuss the kitchen
um that was we talked a lot about the
kitchen last capital budget uh had to be
done need to be done it's not done
that's correct so what what's the scope
of what you what you have accomplished
at this point was it life safety issues
or what would you take care of so uh in
truth the construction work has not
started we have spent a tremendous
amount of time trying to design
something that met that 4.3 million
dollar budget
um and as you know that that kitchen on
that lower level in that that wet dank
area needed to be moved out and as we
started to look at moving it out into
the odd area we started to look at how
it would have to be elevated to a point
where
we were talking some serious increases
in cost with steel and concrete and the
design itself so at this point we have
not done a renovation of the existing
kitchen at all however
um again the plan would be if House Bill
2 is is passed with a 50 million we
would take that money and bring that
back into the existing kitchen where it
is now and make modifications using
we'd have to do some value Engineering
in using like dining hall three and some
of the other places that are out of that
area as a food prep area we're also
actually this afternoon we're talking
with some peop some vendors who might be
able to help us augment it with some
food coming in from the outside so
there's a multitude of things we can do
differently if we don't have to build
this Behemoth of a brand new kitchen
elevated outside into the yard area
excuse me and
um
it just helped me with my memory your
projects are overseen by the public
works department State yeah
okay and just to the point of additional
clarification we were using the existing
kitchen capital budget appropriation to
shore up the existing kitchen to stem us
until we move into a new facility it
doesn't completely Rectify but we would
be working hand in hand with Health and
Human Services the best that we can in
the space some other historical issues
that were not contemplated were we found
some coal Pockets underneath the ground
that interfered with the infrastructure
and putting a structure where we would
prefer the adjacency to our existing
dining room and numerous other
complications started to arise as we
dove into the scope of this project
thank you uh your your one more and I'll
come to you your your other money is our
famous what what you refer to it as the
muffin grinder
they um so just help me understand that
a little better so we identified the
problem the the town the city wanted you
to move it from where it was and make
improvements but now it turns out that's
not what we need to do and we need to
build the structure so no I'm sorry if I
misspoke it's still plan a we're still
going to do exactly what the city asked
us to do which is bring the line down
into our yacht and get that off from
North State Street because every time we
plug up
and we plug up quite a bit we bring in a
outside company that does jetting
services and we flush that line out so
the rest of the city can get their
Seward moving sewer line moving down
Hall Street so this would bring our
lines together on our side of the road
so the problem would be all ours okay
thank you
um uh code now to representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my questions it's actually a
two-part question instead of doing a
follow-up
uh part A of that question is dealing
with the radios uh and you indicated
that they were analog radios which uh
the rest of the law enforcement services
I don't believe have analog radio so I
would imagine with a yes or no that kind
of hinders your ability to talk to the
rest of the public safety force and Part
B of that question is when you migrate
over to a digital system that would also
uh enable you do then to talk to the
rest of the public safety world as the
need is required
uh yes you are exactly correct so yes to
the first part and yes to the second
part and just to remind the committee
probation and parole officers are part
of this department and So that obviously
they're in all of New Hampshire
communities and they will be part and
parcel to this uh radio upgrade
thank you do you have yes I do apologize
I do have one follow-up uh so with the
same type of radios then uh if your
transportation officer is moving uh
people to and from the hospital and our
doctors and stuff they will now have a
radio that will communicate
effectively with the other environment
so they don't have to use a cell phone
or something or something you have to
get the inside track on this sir yes
representative that's exactly what uh we
have for problems when we move between
facilities like from Berlin to Concord
there's dead spots on that two-way radio
because we don't have the repeaters that
some of the other agencies do in full
disclosure I worked at Department of
Transportation for 16 years as an
administrator
um the radios that we upgraded in 1996
there
were what we have now at Department of
Corrections so we have a very old radio
system which anybody can monitor when we
have an incident and our our plan would
be and we're and another thing the
department of safety they have a a new
process we go through them to make sure
we're buying the right product and
they're helping us with that purchase so
that that amount was modified and will
be working directly with them on this
purchase if we get the money
thank you
uh representative Newman
thank you best case situation if
studies went on and grounds could be a
site could be identified and ground
could be broken and construction started
what would you think the best situation
would be for a new timeline for a new
structure
so as as you know with the biennium
budget it takes time to do these
projects there'll be quite a bit of um
architecture engineering design we're
held by some certain standards under law
to make sure we build a facility with
programs so to to answer your question
if this was fast tracked all the way
through I
I would have to defer to public works
but I would say between six and eight
years if it was fast tracked all the way
through before we cut the ribbon follow
up
so I I believe I I heard some hesitancy
to spend maybe upwards of seven million
to do the kitchen but if you could keep
it together
but I don't know that it could be kept
together for six or seven years we could
do this if we if we start looking at
this differently now and stop looking at
a complete new design and start putting
money back into equipment as a matter of
fact Heidi laramie's here from our
agency and she's now been working with
public works on buying new equipment for
that existing kitchen as we speak so
that that will be in compliance
yeah representative noon if I could also
add we're also careful that there'll be
some opportunity uh with the budget
process if we needed to come and ask for
smaller amounts to continue to bridge
that kitchen then we would obviously go
through the budgeting process in this
committee to do so
thank you you're welcome
representative Mills
thank you Mr thank you Mr chair uh going
back to the kitchen which we've dealt
with on this as long as I can remember
being on this on this committee uh
has has the health department ever come
in and and
just been appalled and tried to shut
that place down yet because I having
spent a couple of years in Food Service
I don't know how how they even let you
operate like that
I couldn't answer that so um so we
started right out of the gate and and
thank you again for that initial launch
of money the 4.3 million dollars but
immediately thereafter we started to
work directly with public health and
they do come and inspect us every six
months and we do fail inspections quite
often and we do make repairs
um it is a very difficult thing it's
because it's a constant
the area is is got some leaks coming
from a design on a ramp and that's where
one of our major issues are with that
facility as the ramp comes up in over
the bakery
um that's a water issue and beyond that
as you'll see in some of the slides a
little later on I've got pictures of the
quarry tile that's broken up the kettles
which you'll see the tarps that we we
came up with an idea we saw it uh I
started RV place where they have tarps
with hose clamps in the middle and
that's what we started to uh to put into
the facility just to keep the water
going the right direction so are they
appalled
maybe that's too strong a word are they
are Partners yes we are working with
them I just spoke to them two weeks ago
on a conference call
thank you
um well we have a little bit of time
here
um so
I've had the pleasure of touring both
the Old and the new and when we went to
the women's prison it was had just been
completed and we were walking through
so that was that was a major project a
major build
um what if what have you learned what
have been the downfalls of x if I
remember right we were using panelized
walls and so forth we're now about to
Embark into a much larger facility what
have you learned that will be done
better the next time around
good question good question we we did
learn quite a bit from that as as many
you know that was a construction manager
at risk project the first one the state
has ever done so we scoped every single
trade and got the best what we call
Guaranteed maximum price on paper and
signed to us so that this guy is going
to do the flat work this guy's going to
bring in the panelized construction and
the reason we did that is because we
didn't have enough money to really do
what we intended to do so we did a
tremendous amount of value engineering
to make sure that we could include the
ball field and the gymnasium and the
porticos and the things that we really
needed in the structure so what we
learned from that is construction
manager management at risk
being new to the state was a little
difficult because most all of us who
worked for the state for quite some time
I have 28 plus years in we work on a low
bid and that's a type of project that
we're familiar with so when you talk
about okay now you're the general
contractor you've got a construction
manager working with you and you're
making these choices on everything you
build
it was time consuming
um very time consuming uh seven six days
a week many times I think that that
project took a lot longer as as we
needed to come back to you and ask for
more money another 12.6 million to
complete it
um I think looking at this a different
way and using standard materials and a
a design which reduces recidivism is
really what we need to do and there's
many new designs out there around uh
around the world some of the best in
Scandinavia I'm not suggesting we build
that but that these new designs that
really as I say the punishment's already
there they're confined they're under our
control the facility and the way the
Concord prison is set up now it just
doesn't work
I've got a list here of 121 work orders
maintenance work orders just from the
beginning of December
um and just to highlight a few of them
locks and doors are us because we're a
prison
um
just picking a few metal plates over
holes and steam lines come through that
that's a serious issue fire suppression
systems not working uh
uh Windows shattered doors won't open
kitchen exterior door needs to be
replaced these are just in the last
three months and that's because we
double bunked that facility we
overworked many of the mechanisms and as
time went on everything worked Beyond
its usable life and uh
so to answer your question to build a
new prison
would be something we're familiar with
on the property but as far as the design
goes we'd work heavily with Public Works
a good partners there and hire an
Architects and engineer through their
vetting process who knows these things
and get it done right
thank you did you have a question
I don't think it's a great moment okay
okay thank you further questions yes
representative boy
thank you Mr chairman commissioner
director thank you for your testimony so
far regarding the the sewer
when you reposition that sewer is that
going to be be aligned with the proposed
project that that that everything's
gonna this new through line that's going
to go in that when you transition to the
new facility we're not re Reinventing
the well by having to recreate a new
sewer line good question
um we have a large um arched sewer line
that comes through the prison right now
that actually feeds from the women's
prison right down through to North State
Street so we would continue to use that
line as far as I know
um there may be some nuances where we
could come down call Street or Palm
Street but depending on where the new
prison would be located but yes this
wouldn't be bad this wouldn't be wasting
money to do this project because we're
going to need this muffin monster
regardless for the women's prison and
everything else we build up behind that
so it's it's necessary it's not a change
dramatic change in where that line would
go there's only really one track if any
of you folks are familiar with the Old
Concord Electric now the unitel building
McGuire Street once the Smoke Stack
properties right down that bank right
along the railroad track it's direct
drive all the way to Hull Street so when
we send things down there like blankets
and assorted other items I go down and
identify them and
people do flush a lot and this will
prevent that from actually reaching Hall
Street and causing us to do a massive
cleanup down there
thank you any further questions from the
committee represent Cloutier uh thank
you Mr chairman uh can you tell me and I
realize it varies today what is the
current population of the Men's prison
in Concord
uh thank you representative Clover I
believe I said it's approximately 1200
men this morning okay thank you I'm
sorry no it's all right uh can I follow
up please Mr chairman what is there a
certain capacity though of the it's 1200
now and in other words for safety
reasons and if it went over would you
transfer any prisoners I guess it would
be to the Berlin facility or another
facility if it went over a certain
figure
represent includer that's a reasonable
question we do those transfers on a
regular basis between the two facilities
and yes we look to see if we can balance
capacity and Staffing by making those
transfers
um I will let you know we did two
summers ago shut down the second floor
Hancock building because we had that
opportunity in a population reduction as
I continue to watch the admission rate
at the within the organization I have to
look very long and hard about whether I
open that second floor because that
means approximately 14 new posts that
I'd have to be filling every day with an
already challenged Staffing pattern
and one further just further questions
Mr chairman I mean if if you reached and
I mean a hypothetical over capacity it
was thought of and because I heard from
an informed source that the federal
prison in Berlin has a lot of XX
capacity and I I don't know whether
that's true or not but if you thought if
you had to have contingency plans if
there was too much too many inmates
especially in Concord I mean maybe even
Berlin too the facility there of
reaching out to the federal of an
emergency I don't just speculation uh
that's a fair speculation having worked
with the federal bureau prisons during
covid I know that I would have to have a
federal agreement with them and we'd
have to go through that process both at
the federal level then at the state
level
um I've heard they've been underused
under utilized over utilized and when I
reach out to that Ward at that facility
I I find the facts and in fact as of
recently the Federal Bureau of Prisons
did move large buses of individuals to
that facility and there was some Scuttle
in the community asking if that was us
doing large bus transfers to our
facility but I think it's a reasonable
area we would not leave unexplored okay
okay thank you commissioner thank you Mr
chairman you're very welcome thank you
any other further question yes
representative
oh thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
answering my question
I see that there's a preliminary study
and and that so some of the questions
question I asked might have that's what
the purpose of the study is but do you
have an idea of the ideal size as far as
the number of individuals to be
incarcerated in a new prison is is there
goal you have right now or is that
something that you're gonna will come
out of the study
representative Edgar that is a great
question and having gone through the
women's prison project and also looked
at larger scoped projects across the
country
uh calculating by classification level
based on the history of the department
is part of the design process and I want
to say that when we built the women's
prison the calculations were accurate we
moved in and filled that location and
when the legislature was mindful to be
prepared for us to build another housing
unit in the event we needed it we we
would have been able to do that the
fortunate change was that the reduction
in women becoming incarcerated happened
so we're using about half the capacity
today so your question is so important
that we look at what our history is in
incarceration that we look at what the
legislature and the Judiciary does on
sentencing and trying to forecast that
the best way that we can so that we
don't build something too small and end
up we were as a state in 2010 and 11
which is the reason the infrastructure
at Men's has eroded so quickly because
we quickly almost doubled the design
build capacity of that facility and in
addition to over the over the capacity
even of our North Country facility where
we had upwards of 730 people and
converted gyms to dorms which we don't
have today
okay thank you you're welcome
any further questions yes representative
Newman
thank you
I heard on public radio just the other
day that the National Guard was going to
be assisting with your Staffing they'll
have some training but how quickly will
they be able to start
thank you representative Newman yes as a
last uh Resort and request which is what
we reserve that ask for we're asking for
less people than we did the last time if
that's the shining lining we're asking
for 18 the governor authorized that they
will begin their training next week just
as we did the last time with the hope
that we'll have those resources on posts
which are non-direct posts they're
control rooms that are unarmed
by March 18th is Our Hope
thank you thank you
seeing no further questions thank you
thank you oh I'm sorry did you did you
want to continue on on your slide
presentation or are you okay where we
are I think it's uh fair to say we just
want to point out in the slide deck we
took pictures of all of the areas and
all the priorities
um to show you we don't want to throw
bad money at an infrastructure that's
degrading we're really looking for your
support to the hb2 items to really move
the state and this organization in a
positive direction in addition to on
slide seven we give you some
infrastructure needs and then on slide
eight I want to be mindful we did try to
find a path forward to bring that
project to this committee as is the
history of the state and your collective
intelligence around capital budget
infrastructure so we did talk with the
state treasurer and you'll see on slide
eight some several questions that we
asked of of her that she provided to us
as we were trying to say how do we do
this in the state of New Hampshire how
do we move such a significantly large
price project forward so if you have any
questions on any areas of the slide deck
pictures certainly I think tell a lot
and we incorporate the costs and then on
the very last page we have a list of the
current projects and I know we'll be
back here on Monday to talk about those
as well
yes first time Jack did you have
anything else that you wanted to no
we'll we'll see you Monday on the last
page thank you so much
and thank you all for your service to
the state thank you commissioner
all right we will be in uh recess until
uh 1 p.m when we will have the
Department of Environmental Services
foreign
members want to take a seat please
time being close to one we will open
back up
and start in with the Department of
Environmental Services
commissioner Scott is nice to have you
here in that good looking crew you
brought in with you so
if you would sir take us through your
um your requests
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee again I'm Bob Scott
commissioner of the Department of
Environmental Services I have with me I
have the brains of the outfit on the
budgets uh issues is uh our chief
operating officer Susan Carlson and I
haven't as as alluded to uh I don't
usually call them the good looking crew
but you can uh they got rainy back here
we have a ready Pelletier our Water
Division director Craig Wright our
air Resources Division director and our
assistant director for our Waste
Management uh division uh Sarah yuhaus
Kearns also and then to support us and
the the final uh batting cleanup is uh
Kathy Beam with the air division so
thank you thank you all for being here
welcome to Public Works
so uh you do have the handout I
understand uh so I'm starting with the
the second page uh summer of requests
I'll go through these individually uh in
the following pages but uh we are asking
for uh
support for it infrastructure again I'll
go into the details groundwater
monitoring our drinking water State
revolving Loan Fund match our clean
water State revolving Loan Fund match
and uh funds for Dam repairs and
reconstruction so I'll go in detail for
each one of those we do want to note
that there is a typo
in the documentation for the drinking
water State revolving alone fund match
it's overstated by forty thousand
dollars so as you see in our handout It
should read
10488 283
not 488
so so there's a cost savings right there
so if we can
so moving to the the next uh page three
uh this is the the detailed breakout for
it infrastructure I understand some of
this uh was likely talked to at the doit
discussion with commissioner Goulet I
believe so the first uh line in the the
the most impactful line as far as
expense is the our One-Stop database uh
so uh again we we Endeavor and continue
to expand our presence for e-permitting
uh public information access GIS mapping
and and our reporting we have reporting
requirements for a lot of our federal
our
environmental information uh to the
federal government and they have very
very uh
yeah precise for one of a better word uh
requirements that we have to meet to to
get that data to them uh in all those
cases the more we're able to automate
those more more we're able to have them
accessible online uh report reporting to
Us online and from Us online the more
efficient we become so that this is very
important to us so this first first
large project for One Stop is to
continue the work that we've already
started to to modernize that the the
good news bad news is the more we we put
online the more customers in in our
constituents uh I think rightly so
expect to see it online so we have to
maintain what we're currently doing
while we improve it at the same time so
it's a little bit like fixing your car
as you're driving down the road but uh
we're we're we're we're asking for funds
to continue to do that uh the second uh
line item is for upgrades to our air
monitoring stations uh we run a network
of a dozen air monitoring stations all
throughout the state uh these are we
liked again to get these as automated as
possible uh which uh saves saves uh
staff time to drive and visit them and
and also uh helps uh again the public is
now expecting to see the data that we
collect almost real time so this helps
get us there so this will allow upgrades
upgrades to to those stations as well as
uh purchase of a a mobile auditing and
calibration platform to to to to move
between these sites so we can meet
Federal requirements uh for our air
monitoring the third item is uh is uh
basically uh digitizing uh for our
subsurface Bureau I know the chair is
very familiar with this uh we we have
begun digitizing records from 2015 on
this will allow us to go back we have we
have uh documents going back to the 60s
and this will allow us to get those
scanned and put in the system so they're
available electronically not only to our
staff while we do our work but also to
the to the public uh we think that will
that's uh
a a uh be a very value-added uh Endeavor
to do that the fourth uh item in this
listing is our regarding our our water
lab uh we handle thousands of samples uh
annually and they're tracked currently
through uh uh for those who who are
probably of my age also uh remember
Microsoft Access so this is kind of a
do-it-yourself database so that's where
they're currently currently handled we
want to upgrade that to again to be a
much more uh
accessible uh and more professional
database uh for one of the better words
that's better makes it easier for the
public and us to to get at that data in
our fifth um
item here has to do with our public
bathing our Pools and Spas program uh so
as a caveat it may not be obvious this
is kind of one of the cats and dogs that
are fall under the Des purview so we
have a a program that that is
responsible for basically it's a public
safety uh issue for Pools and Spas uh
that that are regulated uh if we go back
in time before covid uh some of you may
remember we had a Legionella outbreak in
Hampton uh and there there is you know
unfortunately that resulted in some
deaths uh based with on that experience
that was an unregistered Spa
uh that wasn't even in our program but
what should have been uh we now have
there was legislation since then to
require registration uh by Pool owners
uh annual recertification and then
operator training and certification uh
as this new new enhanced program spins
up we want this to be as web enabled as
possible also just for the same reasons
I talked about One Stop we want our
staff to minimize the number of Staff we
need to run the program but also make it
more accessible to the regulated
community and to be blunt in this case
so the average citizen can go online and
see that the the pool they're sending
their children to is is is in compliance
so
so our next slide here is is titled
ground well monitoring network uh this
this line item uh we have existing
ground uh water uh Wells throughout
about 30 throughout the state currently
this will add as the slide mentions 25
new new wells as well as Telemetry again
so we can get this real-time reporting
uh for both the citizenry as well as our
staff this is particularly important
we've gone three years now in the state
of New Hampshire uh we are different
parts of the state state have been in
severe drought and this really will help
us to to be able to monitor that and
also to be blunt help predict that
coming and coming in of drought as well
as coming out of drought uh one of the
issues we have is even with the current
30 Wells uh 11 of those are groundwater
and we really need excuse me uh our most
of these are surface water wells and we
really need the wells to be to be
productive for this type of use they
need to be further deeper in groundwater
Wells so this will get us closer to that
that point also
and again obviously Mr chair I can take
questions anytime anybody would like
um okay why don't we do that uh
commissioner let's
um go ahead represent me on the
digitizing uh historical documents
involved going back to the 60s 750
000 because that do everything back six
piece forward to the iron space
allocation you're doing and what is the
timeline to get it done yeah I'm going
to defer to I don't know if Sue knows
that answer I I'm not sure I'm willing
to guarantee we'll get every document
for that that amount of money if that's
your question
that was the question in helping us
right into the County County registered
Deeds this seems a little on the pricing
side but maybe the location or access
from the records and you know the at
least in the county environment
no matter how much money you give them
they can only do so many documents when
they allocated time sequence so this is
a multi-year project and if so we find
pretty much money a lot of time
yeah
that's a lot of questions
um essentially
um
this we have we've kind of essentially
we have
um
estimated and and calculated out that we
have approximately 750 000 records from
1986 to 2015.
um and at the price that they are asking
that will get us every all of those
documents done and then while they're
doing that we're going to have staff go
back through the really old documents
clean those and then work with those
we're going to work to get those done we
are looking at
probably two years between the time we
start this and when all of these
documents will be done
this is not a fast process
in a lot of these documents are
oversized
so it makes it even harder or takes
longer to scan
thank you I'd like to follow up on that
and then I'll come back to you
representative so when when you're going
through this and I applaud you I mean
this is this is documentation that towns
can't find and homeowners can't find so
this is fantastic when you when you're
going through this process
you will do the actual plans and just
now show operational approvals and that
sort of thing
thank you
yes representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so in your I.T
infrastructure proposal
where is cyber security and and
um how are you protecting yourself from
all those great people out there who
want to lock you up with some ransomware
for those who know me that's a an issue
that's near and dear to my heart
actually so again that's all this work
we work very closely with uh doit and to
be blunt a lot of this work the upgrades
that type of thing needs to be done uh
for a lot of reasons but one of them is
for cyber security when you're when the
a lot of the original coding that was
done is not compliant with that type of
requirement uh we have some Sometimes
some embedded here is some software
systems are not compliant with that so
that is another great reason that you
bring up why this work needs to be done
to keep us in that mode and I and I will
say and I think represent I know
representative McConkey will remember
the chair will remember
some years back we actually pulled our
database offline because we had done a
a a a doit had contracted with an
auditor to look at and they they had
they had basically done some penetration
testing of our systems and that was a
problem and and so I felt it was very
painful if I think for everybody but I
felt we didn't want to lose that data
and we we felt we didn't have a choice
but to to bring it offline recode to
take some of those vulnerabilities out
and then put it back on
thank you are you all set representative
okay thank you on um yes representative
Dolly please
hello
pull your microphone down to yourself
I just don't know a lot about your
department
are you is this department that's
monitoring
the trash the multi-state trash dumping
in the state doing water samples around
it
yes that's that's with a regulatory
Agency for Waste Management which is
landfills hazardous waste uh chemicals
Etc in that respect the burning of trash
in Manchester which they tell me
represents 27 percent of our air
pollution in the state
I'm not I'm not aware of that factoid
but but yeah so so I think you're
talking about the sludge incinerator is
that that sound correct I suppose I
guess
I guess when they burn
trash
Hospital waste incinerator I know I have
director right here uh so those are
subject to federal regulations and most
of them have shut down I believe
yeah so so there was a time when medical
waste incinerators were were doing that
Federal requirements came in and and the
the cost of compliance was such that
they decided just to ship it off instead
thank you you're welcome thank you uh
represent Newman
thank you just
just do you are you practicing good uh
backup and and backup practices yes
again so we work closely with Duit and
that's certainly an element of what we
do uh for a lot of reasons uh you know
there's some senses instances that the
data will go to the cloud protecting
that's very important but even just
cyber security aside just to the extent
you have data on a server and the server
fails that's a you know that that's a
bad practice not to have a backup
thank you uh commissioner Vaca goes
commissioner Scott if I can go back to
phase two uh to replace the One-Stop
system
are is it replacing or is it or are you
adding programs to it
I I think we'd say both both I think and
and that's why sometimes when we talk
about replacing One Stop you know one
stop as you're probably aware has kind
of evolved over the years right so it's
what 28 different databases that have
kind of so you know my view is one stop
is our
is what we call our enterprise system to
to have e-permitting and environmental
data available to us all so so it's a
little bit of both so but but we do want
to be
we need to revamp the system we have and
again as I mentioned uh not to be
repetitive but the other challenge is
rightly so uh
the citizenry and our clients expect the
existing services to be maintained while
we're transitioning and improving so
it's so it's a multi-faceted dance if
you will in in your Department's efforts
uh where are you with uh subsurfaces is
a great example of e-permitting and it's
working very well
um how close are we to or where do you
see down the line that we'll get
Shoreland which I think would be easier
than getting Wetlands but I to have
those documents available are equally as
important many times in Shoreland and
I'm wondering if you could speak to that
so I may give over to that our assistant
commissioner Mark Mark Sanborn I I
didn't I think he wasn't in the room
when I when I announced everybody if I
was I apologize if he was I apologize to
him I know he is now uh so maybe I'll
ask him if you don't mind to come up and
please Sue can scoot over for a bit
he's been uh I I don't know if it's an
enviable task or an enviable task but
he's been been working with doit very
closely in our our team on the the
database work
thanks commissioner for the record Mark
Sanborn assistant commissioner and uh
all duties as assigned by the
commissioner so I'm happy to do all of
them
um so a couple of things uh relating
back to a number of the questions so the
digitalization item on the list that is
specifically to focus in on our lrm
which the programs you're mentioning are
under
um to get those online and accessible
electronically versus
um in hard form only which is the way it
is right now another thing I wanted to
mention about that the One-Stop efforts
in addition to it just being good
practice getting those digitized we need
them to be digitalized for one stop to
fully work because you need those
documents your subsurface is a great
example of that
um so where we are just stepping back
phase one of our current One-Stop effort
is Data Warehouse cleanup so we are
going through the process of
um the Legacy at DES is at the time the
way a lot of programs did it is they
built their own
software using with the help of doit and
they had data of their own databases so
which was standard practice you know for
for a while and across the board what
we're doing right now is the phase one
is to take all of our databases
get all our documents loaded
electronically and consolidation of all
our databases through Oracle and then
also utilizing oracle's iCloud to have
them all moved up to to the cloud so
that's phase one which you should see a
contract for by July in front of GNC for
the the first phase one of the funding
we actually just this week we're
interviewing the finalists for the RFP
process
phase two is then taking the now
accessing the databases with modern
programs in order to be able to
interface with the public so you could
start accessing them while we're doing
all this I'm sure you're all aware the
governor used some of the arpa funding
for
um
um to do some uh efficiency improvements
for uh the e-permitting efforts with us
and Dot
um so we are in addition working with
DOT right now for some examples of some
pilot projects using Salesforce as the
platform to be able to have those online
even faster than the overall effort we
have going and the programs you
mentioned chairman are Are all uh
included in in what's being considered
sure we're not starting with Shoreland
because while simpler than Wetlands is
still more complicated so we're we're
utilizing some smaller programs to show
just the applicability in terms of
Permitting e-permitting for Salesforce
um and then with the uh idea of working
with the oit and including them
Shoreland is on that list of ones we are
considering doing through that pilot
project with that set of funding so our
goal is to get as much online get as
much digitalized as possible as quickly
as possible get as much online e-pard
meeting as quickly as possible but doing
it in a way so that the larger efforts
we're working on it's all compatible
with that and will eventually get to the
goal that every governor of the century
has talked about of having a single
portal that the the businesses and
residents of the state can go to and
then access the program they need to
um and perform whatever work they need
to whether it's a permit where there's a
back and forth uploading other documents
and of course paying the fees required
thank you sir any any questions Miss
Sanborn while we have them here
thank you for that sir thank you
do you want to continue thank you so now
moving on to slide five so a a
historically the state has both what's
called clean water uh and for those who
are yet initiating clean water would
think would be something you'd drink
it's actually
Wastewater and storm water this is an
EPA term uh State revolving Loan Fund
and the drinking water uh State reload
revolving loan funds so we have a
baseline historically that we've gotten
from from the federal government this is
uh you know the Congress moves decides
how much money that that goes out
on their on the base basis uh this this
cycle now and for the next five years
the infrastructure Bill uh increased our
srf allocations that that was a
mechanism by which they they decided to
flow money to the states and and so
there's three pots of money there's the
supplemental grants which will basically
to take our existing srf programs and
plus them up there's a new new pot of
money through that process called
emerging contaminants and there's one
also for letting copper line
Replacements uh both uh neither the
emerging contaminant or lead and copper
funds require State match but we do see
again we're seeing a significant
increase as outlined in the slide for
our our Baseline drinking water and
clean water srf so so uh you know the 20
match that's required uh is is reflected
in this in this capital budget request
any questions on that before we
um one one question if I could so do you
have any idea commissioner how New
Hampshire fares in that money that is uh
that is sent out there for drinking
water and clean water I know when we
look at the amount of money that New
Hampshire receives for federal highways
we receive the least of any other state
I'm wondering if you have a feeling of
where we sit with the feds on this money
so so these are the funding for these
type of funds out of the infrastructure
bill that we're talking about are
formula base so so it's it's a set set
for our state so as as I was just
reminded so New Hampshire based on our
size is a what they're saying is a one
percent state so we're getting one
percent of it so it's proportional we
are in a position I will say not every
State's been able to digest these type
of funds so they're not all taking them
uh I think we position ourselves very
well in the state to make use of every
dime the federal money they care to give
us so we are well positioned in that
respect but the short answer is based on
our formula we're taking everything and
it's we're a one percent State thank you
please continue
so moving to slides oh I'm sorry I was
there for a question yes that should be
uh thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question
um I was comparing the uh the amounts
that you're requesting on uh on page two
to what was in your submittal to the to
the governor and you've decreased the
amounts uh could you explain to me the
difference
yes
um it's a timing issue uh when we
originally put together our capital
budget request it was nearly a year ago
and we were given estimates from EPA as
to what our base grants were going to be
um clean water was estimated at over 16
million dollars drinking water was
pretty close to that the final awards
that have come in are significantly
below that
drinking water came in in a seven
million dollars and clean water came in
at a little over 11 million dollars and
so that is what is driving down our
budget request
follow up representative uh thank you
um so
in some cases we find that the believing
Federal money on the table because we
didn't request a match I assume for what
you just said that we're uh we are
matching any money available from the
federal government yes
yes thank you thank you represent mayor
anyone else
foreign
yeah again that is our goal is to to
make sure our our taxpayers get every
dime they can from the federal
government
um so the next slide I'm going to have
uh Susan Carlson address but it
basically it's it said well she can
describe it better so but it will show
the impact of the srf funding on on the
request
I did is because this request is um so
far out of the norm for the amount that
we normally request for match what I did
was put a table together for both
Federal fiscal years 24 and 25 and
essentially our base Awards because the
base award for both grants is the same
for both years 11 million for clean
water 7 million for drinking water the
base award for both is 18 and a half
million but the supplemental awards are
adding 45 and 49 million dollars to our
request and these all require the 20
match which is what why our request is
higher than we have in past bienniums so
in total between Federal fiscal year 24
and 25 we're looking at 131 million
dollars in federal funds which requires
approximately a 26.2 million dollar
match
um by our current calculations we have
4.4 million dollars of match on hand
which brings down our rec cost for the
biennium for both programs to 21.8
million
okay
yeah excuse me uh representative
just out of curiosity when we accept
these grants from the federal government
are we giving up any of our water rights
to the federal government
are oversight of any oversight or
anything dealing with our water no sir
yes uh representative thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question I I'm sorry because I'm new on
the committee but so when you say it's a
match this is a match by the state or is
it a match that the state also collects
from local communities it is a match by
the state thank you
yes representative
just because there are several new
members here
um
would you mind telling what
the percentage is of State dollars to
federal dollars for the agency overall
having done years on finance I'm
familiar but
okay
I if I'd known you're asking that
question I would have brought my other
budget book
um right now
um we are at
five for five percent General funds
we are at 36 36 federal funds and the
balance is fee and other funds
okay if that's I'll move the next slide
then if I could yep uh so slide seven as
promised is about Dam repairs and
reconstruction uh this this uh slide
outlines the the two the two major ass I
I will caveat that historically we
actually asked for a lot more for dams
and for those who aren't aware of the
capital budget we were we were fortunate
to be able to use some repayment funds
from arpa those were programmed in uh so
we were able to take 30 million of that
and we we for those who aren't aware for
for damn work there's there's over 260
dams in the state and we rack and stack
the needs of you know depending on the
hazard qualification what the damage
would happen if you know if they were to
fail and the condition and we have a
running list of who needs to work as you
may imagine a lot of these dams are over
100 years old so you know we have we
have a lot of needs so we were very
fortunate to have arpa money's program
to the tune of 30 million for for
state-owned dams uh that we're currently
using uh and that's why
you see a relatively modest request it
may not seem modest to you but based on
past years it's very modest uh so so I
say that so for context and also
trust me next biennium we will be asking
for a much larger amount again because
it's just because of the need so I just
want to especially for the new members
so in this case we're talking
um for the ask here we're talking two
dams one is as identified as the Israel
River ice dam so that was created uh the
the that's ice dam uh
just for those who know it's it's meant
to break up ice dams it's not a dam of
of the water uh it was constructed in
1981 uh by the Army Corps of Engineers
and again contacts was for those who
aren't aware when you have an ice dam uh
or a buildup of ice that that blocks
things it actually causes flooding so
this was this dam was created in 1981 by
the Army Corps of Engineers to help
prevent those those things from
happening on uh in Lancaster uh once the
Army Corps finished that damn by
agreement they turned it over to the the
town for operation and maintenance of
that uh for many reasons the dam hasn't
been maintained and now we have a dam
who's who's
um
design was to to reduce and eliminate
ice dams since it's not been been
maintained it absolutely now causes ice
dams uh so since it hasn't been
maintained uh our desire is to remove it
we had to go through a official uh
process for the federal government to
deauthorize that and that that came in
as of December of 22. so now this money
would be to remove that that Hazard that
that's created now
uh this the second so it's not a great
story uh this the second uh is for our
hydrological uh data collection system
we have 32 stations throughout the state
uh this allows uh on the damn side it
again to the extent that we can see uh
changes whether it's storms or just
water levels in general what helps us
manage our dams throughout the state so
it helps maintain the safety of the dams
in our operations uh this is again as we
discussed with RIT systems generally we
have a lot of old outdated hardware and
software uh in including cyber security
hazards uh that we need to to see
upgrades here so that that's what that
250 000 reflects for this day
will will there be more locations added
or is it an upgrade with what you have
this unless I'm corrected this is to
replace this is to replace and upgrade
our existing okay
thank you
and then uh
yeah well we still oh yeah I was gonna
say uh so then our our last uh
additional request has to do which is
slide eight uh for those who are
following along is for the Winnipesaukee
River Basin uh so for again uh for the
benefit of the the new members who
aren't familiar with us uh we own the
state owns and operates uh a wastewater
treatment facility that serves 10
communities in the in Frank Franklin is
the location of the uh wastewater
treatment facility we are the only
agency Like Us in the state in the
country rather that that that has this
Enterprise under us which is a little
bit odd for us we regulate wastewater
treatment facilities and we operate one
and and so it's staffed by Des employees
um the the Winnipesaukee River Basin is
funded by the 10 10 communities they
they don't take any general well I
shouldn't say I'm sure they'd love to
have General funds but they're not
funded with General funds uh and uh the
the the the funds that go through them
are are paid for through assessments
user assessments basically for the 10
communities so in this case their ask is
uh for replacement of what we call Force
Mains so basically it's the the mains
that are carrying sewage uh to the
facility uh there's about two two and a
half miles worth of of Maine that is is
in need of replacement it was originally
installed in 1983 uh as you may imagine
depending on the soil conditions the the
the the steel the metal tends to corrode
uh they're starting to see with the
corrosion they're starting to see uh
some uh some some uh
leakage
and this is to replace that uh and again
as you're well aware uh it's much cost
Effectiveness wise it's much better to
replace before there's a major problem
than than trying to patch when you have
a hopefully not in this case but a guys
were on Main Street that type of thing
so this is what that reflects uh and
again this is uh 100 funded by the the
project participants
thank you
um yes please represent
uh thank you Mr chairman uh I come from
Belknap County and we've just been uh
this past recent month or so we've been
informed of uh approximately 30 percent
increase in our sewer uh increases due
to the Winnipesaukee Basin and I'm just
curious is this
6.7 million part of that 35 percent to
recoup it or is that other than because
there seemed to be part a large
maintenance of of oversight maintenance
that has been I guess delayed over a
period of time as we so I'll start and
then sue us yes thank you so so again
um so you're correct uh in the
operational budget for for you know the
the other committee if you will uh we do
have programmed in which what amounts to
basically is a 25 increase uh based on
past past history and that's primarily
reflective of moving water and waste is
very energy intensive
uh it's reflective of which I'm sure
you've all seen with your own household
bills it's reflective of energy price
increases Commodities the chemical feeds
that we need and that type of thing have
all gone up uh exponentially uh and
you're mentioned maintenance so there
there are some instances where as I
mentioned you know we we like to be
proactive in what we're doing uh to save
rate payers money uh during covid the
the availability units we're still
seeing a little bit of materials and
contract work to do certain maintenance
that we'd like to have done wasn't
available so there's a certain amount of
deferred maintenance that that is
embedded in into that that increase if
you will also as you're probably aware
there the 10 communities have
Representatives we have a board that
that this all goes through and and they
agree before these things happen uh also
so I'm not as familiar with your system
you say there's a 30 increase
okay so so that my point is some of that
increase certainly would be from our
operations but each one of those 10
communities have their own collection
systems and they that they have to
maintain as well as staff that may do
that maintenance also and that
that we don't control obviously so the
extent that your town has
Mains that are feeding us that need work
or they have they'll to be blunt
materials Etc they have the same type of
cost increases if it is 30 that's
probably why it's more than our increase
because they have their own increases on
top of it but that's a guess under 30
percent
so I don't know if that helped or not
but I can so did you have something that
you wanted or added
um just so you understand this is a
capital budget request
um we are going to be going through the
srf Loan program to attain a below
market rate loan for this the
communities in the operating budget will
not see an increase on this until we
finish this project which is probably
three three and a half years down the
road
if if I could follow I'm sorry did you
have a follow-up yes Mr chairman please
so if I understood that what you just
said or maybe I misunderstood it I hope
um that
once this
6.75 is done
and completed that there will be a
charge back to the 10 communities it's
part of The Debt Service payment
um the the when it was talking Reverb
Basin is a self-funded program so when
money is borrowed Capital funds are
borrowed and
um we repay those Capital funds that
Debt Service payment is part of the
operating budget of Winnipesaukee basic
so this is a grant then and not just uh
no I guess I'm confused
because I thought if we did it at a
capital budget that it was paid for by
the capital budget and not the
individual and then what I'm hearing is
that it's going to be paid back by the
individual
receivers of this and I thought this
would be the same as if you're upgrading
your software system and stuff like that
any anything in the capital budget is
bonded debt
debt um whether it is bonded debt
through the state general fund or bonded
debt through other funds
um there is a and unless of course we
receive a Federal Grant in this case we
are bonding this we are not using state
general funds we are
going through the srf Loan program in
order to get a better rate than the
state treasurer can get
um and then the communities as we have
in the past
um when this loan goes into repayment
The Debt Service becomes part of our
operating expenses
and those operating expenses get billed
back to the 10 communities which is why
as the commissioner said there's all
time communities serve on an Advisory
Board
we have a 10-year Capital Improvement
plan
they they review it they go through it
they approve it and
so we make sure that the 10 communities
are all on board before we even ask for
any of this funding
thank you and if I could if if you're
from Belmont you might want to hear not
want to hear this but again this is a
well there you go so this project is in
Belmont and will be primarily paid paid
by for by Belmont ultimately
if I could is this this project here is
is in our capital budget it's not in our
Capital this is we're telling good news
is representative you're going to have a
sewer it might cost you more
so so this might this money does not is
not in our capital budget but this is a
funded project
this this is an additional crust by this
department to be added to the capital
budget
being requested
okay uh secondly um we were fortunate to
get a lot of arpa funds and I know in
the county we have several years to
expend those monies is is there this
would seem to be a qualifying project
have you folks expended all of your arpa
funds and did this not qualify
and could we get a list of what you
spent arpa funds on sure so so just for
orientation again so we've received 185
million dollars of arpa funds uh for
water Wastewater and as I mentioned for
dams uh 35 of that is for Dam so I
mentioned 30 million for state-owned
dams we also uh are this allocation of 5
million for municipally owned dams uh
and of that the remaining funds we've
expense you know we've obligated uh I
want to say on the order of 90 95 what
we're waiting on uh right now is to see
what comes back so what we've done is
we've done
for the primarily municipality but the
water systems or Wastewater systems that
we've we've offered funding through
furarpa
their conditional offers and typically
they have to go to futile meeting so
where we're offering accommodation
typically of
arpa grants and srf loans with a certain
amount of loan forgiveness my hope is
the municipalities this is my commercial
realize that this is the best deal
they're probably going to get in their
lifetime I do expect giving just the way
budgets work and and competing uh
concerns for expenditures that perhaps
not all of it's going to make it through
town meeting if that happens and we
don't know what amount that will be then
then there'll be additional funds
available to reallocate but right now
effectively we revalocated our those
funds already if you like we do have a
report that we produce uh we can
certainly send it out to you uh the
latest one and maybe a couple weeks old
but I think you know
the website oh that's true and we'll
send a report out by email uh and uh
also as Sue mentioned all that is uh all
on our website also so so it's anybody
can see see those expenditures we where
they're going Etc so that answer your
question yeah no I appreciate if you'd
send us a link but I would like to see a
report if we could
they um so is is this request your
highest request
issue number one if more funds can be
found
okay
thank you
I like all my children equally but yes
yeah
so does that conclude your presentation
yes it is always or if there's other
questions later too obviously we're
happy and I think we're coming back
Monday for the subcommittee if I
remember correctly on Labs yes
all right thank you uh thank you for
your attendance
soon I'm sorry representing else did you
have a question
yes thank you could I I just go back to
the Israel River ice dam I just had a
question if I heard correctly it wasn't
maintained correctly so now this Dam
that was in there for a good reason is
going to have to come out who whose job
was it to be maintaining it and is there
a replacement something going in once
it's out
uh I'll go backwards for your question
so no there's not a replacement program
for this uh it's a long labored story
but basically some of the reason why it
wasn't maintained is it was turned over
to the town
I believe the town felt the Army Corps
should pay for the maintenance and the
Army Corps since they turned it over to
the town thought the town should pay for
it so I think that's really the Crux of
why it's it's languished as it has
follow-up yes thank you
I can understand how that could have
happened but when that happens like do
you people go in to sort it out and say
no you got to do it
again this has been decades uh since the
80s obviously so I can't speak to
history but uh
we our responsibility is to make sure
these dams are safe and and don't create
a hazard so that's frankly one of the
reasons why we got to where it is now
because we were we realized that due to
that atrophy if you will of of not
maintaining it was actually creating
flooding and creating problems which is
why we then then we got involved saying
look okay this needs to come out we had
to deal with the Congressional
Delegation to get this these
deauthorized since they were constructed
by the Army Corps uh and uh and that's
why we're here asking for general fund
capital budget money to remove it so
again it's not a great situation but at
this point we feel
you know that's that's the right thing
to do to protect Public Safety
thank you are there any further
questions for the commissioner
uh thank you so much for your time and
uh appreciate having you here once again
we will have our uh dot at two o'clock
two o'clock I'd like to open up a
Department of Transportation
and uh welcome uh commissioner
cast to the table and it's a real
pleasure to have you in this position as
as it is to have you and your staff here
today so thank you and welcome to Public
Works
and I didn't want to tell you you only
got a half hour to get through 500 pages
yeah
at least 15 minutes yeah it'll be quick
so take all the time you need sir
um
thank you Mr chair for the record my
name is William Cass commissioner for
the dot with me are several folks from
the Department to help answer answer
questions if we get into that level of
detail I know the uh book presentation
information probably has a lot of
information I propose to
start high level with with some summary
and before you know developing into the
details if that's if that's fine with
you all and we can get to the level of
questions that that you want answered so
um
I think the best page to start is just
the first page it's kind of the index of
project requests
and gives a a a high level overview of
what our capital budget request entails
so uh Department of Transportation we
end up kind of with uh two phases two
two areas of of Interest one in the
general fund which deals with primarily
our Aeronautics Rail and Transit side of
the house and then the highway fund side
side fund 15 which deals with more of
the dot
our own facilities Patrol sheds salt
sheds and things like that
so starting at the top of that page
general fund tend we had initially
um
we had initially put forward an agency
request of six identified ranked
priority projects for consideration for
general fund funding
right before uh the um
right right before the um
submission the governor's office had
asked us to prioritize to just submit
the the top two
so uh you know for the full clarity
um
the top two are what we presented uh at
the request of the governor's office but
we had identified
um those six as the top priority for for
our consideration
um
so if you turn the page to page
um well it's labeled page one but it's
form 2A which summarizes those general
fund requests and I have to walk you
through this because there was a little
bit of a
I don't know if it was a
miscommunication or a misinterpretation
of our of our information and what came
out in hb2 so the first
um the first
um the first item is for the uh State
match or half of the state match for the
Federal Aviation Administration projects
so we have we get FAA funds through the
dot which go to
the municipalities and the in the
airports uh typically FAA funds are are
90 Federal and the 10 match is split
five percent by the state and five
percent by the municipality or the
airport owner there are a few projects
that that uh percentage may change on
and there are some
um there are some
um
lingering uh
uh relief funded projects which were a
hundred percent federally funded coming
out of some of the covid relief which
impact those percentages
so
um our ask at the agency request was for
1.19 million dollars of state general
funds which would have matched
69.64664 million dollars of federal
funds for a total of
uh 70 million 857 dollars
um
again this is where the the
misinterpretation or miscommunication
had come had come from so in the
governor's budget we in hb2 you'll see
that uh dot was approved for 7 million
87 million 85 807 dollars
um again somebody had read the total saw
that typically the Federal
Aviation funds have matched 90 10 and
they put a 10 percent
funding level in there
so we uh respectfully would would
suggest an adjustment down because we'd
only needed the 1.19 million dollars to
match the FAA funds so adjust the
approved level down by the by the Delta
there of 5.89 million dollars and with
that balance consider funding uh the
remaining uh uh requests that we had had
um
out there
so I'll pause for a minute there are any
questions if that's if that's clear but
essentially
um
what we had asked for on this line
because of that misinterpretation of the
of the matching percentage was was over
funded and the adjustments are labeled
there so it asked for consideration you
know to apply that to the the remaining
items that weren't originally submitted
and we can step through those and I can
stop for either questions or keep going
but it's a little bit confusing I want
to just take time to make sure everyone
understood
oh thank you commissioner the way I
understand this Committee just found
five million 893 thousand dollars that's
the way to look at it exactly sure but
let's uh let's let's go through your
projects uh that you propose to use some
of that money for okay certainly so
um
um so that Priority One again is the is
the match for the Federal Aviation
projects
um our second priority was similarly the
match matching funds for uh for Transit
uh buses and passenger amenities those
are capital federal uh Capital Federal
Transit Authority
um funds they go to primarily
um you know municipal or community-based
Transit providers for replacement buses
uh and Paratransit vehicles
um there's more detail in the in the in
the um in the
um packet for exactly what what what
agencies and stuff would get that but at
a high level that uh five hundred and
seventy thousand dollars would match
foreign
six million dollars or so of of FTA
funds
um so that 570 000 is just the match for
the federal funds to allow about
uh roughly
30 to 35 uh Transit vehicles for the um
for those
um Transit service providers in the
details further in there thank you
the third priority and actually I I'll
kind of take three four and five
um all all together
um
because they they they all pertain to
um uh some funding to address uh needs
along state-owned railroad corridors and
we've bucketed it in kind of three three
asks of of what what what some needs
that have been identified for
um addressing repairs to Railroad
bridges in the first line that's
priority number three
um and a 620 000 request
repairs to culverts
um under and along state-owned railroad
lines which is priority number four
in priority number five which deals with
a request of about five hundred thousand
dollars to address
um railroad ties uh deteriorated
railroad ties along state-owned railroad
lines these are basically maintenance
type of projects to allow us to address
some of the needs and keep up with the
maintenance needs along the state-owned
railroad lines
we have a very small
um
Rail and Transit division uh and and
very
um
limited funding limits that that go to
support the state-owned railroad lines
wholly dependent on requests such as
these
thank you questions yes representative
bill I guess I'm just curious none of
this on the railroad stuff can be
supplanted with infrastructure money
not um
not uh not the formula not the core
formula funds and things that we get if
there was a special project
like uh although it's not our line I
mean I think Kathy had provided the
committee some information on the
Capitol Corridor which was a which was
going to be either an fra or an FTA kind
of federal funded project let me just
pause for a minute and Shelly do I have
that right does yes so worth the shot
thanks yeah
any other questions
okay thank you sure and the uh and the
sixth priority
um is
um
is a is a software system to help us
administer our av Aviation grant program
um we we rely on a very uh dated
um
software program it's a it's an access
database
um type of type of system
um 20 plus years old uh uh it's
functional it's stable it's level it
works but uh
um it's been an identified need to
upgrade that to you know bring us uh
um into the future here to help better
and more efficiently manage those
airport grants but um the existing
system like I said is stable that's why
it's the sixth priority but it is an
identified need to address if that was
if that was to be considered so okay
so if you were to fund
items three through six
uh that would still leave a surplus is
that the way I understand it
actually asking for
yes I mean answer your question yes
because those all total 4.5
uh three 4.5 million dollars and what
was approved was uh seven million
dollars in the general fund side great
would you like to continue
oh questions I'm sorry
um oh thank you Mr chairman thank you
commissioner uh you might be amused to
know that the previous agency also had
an access database so I wouldn't feel
too bad
Thursday
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question those are railroad
ties and uh lines really look sad so
what's the frequency of use on these
lines that that we're talking about
doing the work
um that's why I have some staff Shelley
do you want to help this is Shelly
winter she's our director of Aeronautics
Rail and Rail and Transit thank you
um
I'll let you answer I could speculate I
have a general sense but I'm sure you're
much more articulate on
I'm not sure I'm much more articulate
but uh thank you so there's Federal
Railroad Administration safety standards
and requirements on how many good ties
are required per rail length so right
now because we are band-aiding with ties
that are all
pre-1970s you know I brought a date pin
this is a 1933 date pin we pulled out
last week we're meeting the minimum
standards and requirements under Federal
Railroad Administration guidelines to
maintain a class one or class two so we
have no safety issues currently we're
very diligent about our inspections
we've ramped up our inspections to
include a rail pod which is sort of a
machine that runs on it and can
ultrasonically collect all this
information and data so we're
recommending a strategic replacement of
those that are going to change impact
the safety
and again prioritize based on those that
get the heaviest needs so whether it's
rail to maintain the heavier freight
loads or if it's the tourist Excursion
Services of Conway scenic for the
Plymouth and Lincoln railroad so some of
those get daily use during the um the
tourist season so again moving
passengers were very careful about that
safety and then where the heavier loads
are there's more infrequent use but the
weight is heavier so it's kind of a
balance of prioritization so we use this
data collected to look at the worst
locations or the worst spots and we'll
we'll spot Thai replace those
accordingly
thank you thank you yes Mike represent
beggar yeah Mike yeah thank you Mr
chairman and thanks for the answer it
should be a fairly quick one it has to
do with actually uh line number two
um
the federal match you're talking about
is there more money available if you
came up with more money is there more
money from the feds or you're just
matching up to what you can get from
them now
I think we're just matching what our
anticipated uh funding level uh would
would be I think with some of the
lapsing projects and stuff if there
happen to be more available Federal
Transit money
um I don't believe that the that the
that the state match would be a
limitation is that correct yeah
so they have an equivalent of a capital
investment plan so they have a Transit
Asset Management plan which shows based
on the year of service or the projected
mileage when something is due for
replacement so they have to access the
federal funds in accordance with that
useful life standard so this is our
prognostication of the state funds
necessary to access those based on
federal standards thank you thank you
any further questions yes please
representski
thank you
um how many miles of railroad tracks do
we own the state of New Hampshire
234. so the requests all the requests
before you are for the active railroad
lines which are approximately 200 with
160 of them getting that more regular
use so all the requests before you were
for the active railroad lines so that's
160 miles
correct about 160 miles that have
regular Service 200 miles if we look at
those that are maybe only used
seasonally
are we getting any reimbursement from
people who use companies that are using
those lines
correct The Limited funds that
commissioner Cass spoke to earlier that
the railroad the special railroad fund
that we have access to that's generated
from a percent of gross revenue by our
tenant railroads who use those lines
those contracts go through governor and
Council and we get limited revenue from
a Butters who may have a driveway
Crossing across the railroad quarters or
may lease ancillary Parcels from us so
the special railroad fund and our
maintenance funds are self-generated but
they're limited to those sources I just
identified
okay thank you all right any any further
questions
thank you
you're welcome to stay
no thank you uh if there are no more
questions on the general general fund
side I've moved to the divider there's a
divider in this book uh a green divider
will kind of go to the cap excuse me
make sure we can make go to the capital
side I mean go to the highway fund side
of our Capital request
and that's on page 28 so let me make
sure so it'll probably be easier to just
kind of talk off of this summary and
then go deeper if we need any more
detail so
again a little bit more explanation here
um this is a little bit different than
the general fund side so
at our initial agency request we had
identified this this list of 11
priorities for consideration for
for uh Capital funding
at the um right before the June
submission uh the governor's office had
asked us to only submit or I'll take our
our top three priorities to to submit
so that's why there's a dividing line
here between here so those top three
priorities for the salt salt and sand
sheds underground fuels fuel tanks
replacement and the crew quarters were
our top three priorities that we had
submitted with our official agency
capital budget request but our initial
agency budget Capital request had
included all 11 prioritized needs
and
um coming out of hb2
again because of and I think you've
heard the concerns about
um you know where we are with interest
rates and and things like that that has
their their uh there wasn't there wasn't
in the governor's uh budget a will to
um consider funding for any of our
highway-funded Capital needs so that's
why uh and the approved side not none of
none of these were approved in the
governor's official hb2 budget
with that said I would like to advocate
for our top three priorities
um
one of the things that that we have
found over the years is that if we don't
keep up with some regular investment
regular
um maintenance of these facilities
we get very far behind and we have a
long list so I know some of all of the
members of the committee uh probably
know this but we have about a hundred
Patrol sheds and remote
um not remote but but maintenance
facilities Patrol sheds around the state
that are responsible for maintaining all
of the all of the state highways
so
um
we tend to get uh with this level of
funding and cost of going up
with the fuel with the um with the salt
and sand sheds we tried to do two
two to four depending on the budget
depending on the type of sand assault
shed that that needs to be done
two to four salt sheds of biennium
um
and and try to keep up with that so you
can do the do the math we have about a
hundred or more you know Statewide to
maintain and keep up and they're all in
various ages and years but uh
you know my concern uh our concern I
should say is that if we don't have some
level of of regular maintenance
particularly for those items we get very
far we get very far we get behind the
eight ball and trying to keep up with
that level of of of
Maintenance so
um the first item of our priority like I
said usually every budget every capital
budget every two years we do
um
um look for for some funding to again
keep up with that regular uh maintenance
that regular routine of of replacing and
acting on those 100 or so Statewide salt
and sand shed facilities so this
um
two million dollars would again we would
anticipate trying to address two two to
four sand and salt sheds uh and replace
those in the details of the book there
are a number of uh priorities within
there that we would identify
um without turning to the page I know
we've identified Northampton uh Lincoln
we'll have to look at the third one but
there are several in a list that we've
identified that need to be replaced
one of the interesting things about the
Northampton shed is um with the
replacement of the salt shed there we
are looking to also incorporate some
cold storage that is at a remote
facility which would free up that remote
facility for a uh for a Trailhead for a
currently under construction rail trail
from Hampton to to Greenland the site
that we own would be a perfect Trailhead
access to that site it would also
provide efficiency to have all that cold
storage on site and not two or three
miles away
so that's one of the higher priorities
that we've identified with this with
this priority number one
priority number two is underground fuel
tank replacement
again at those 100 or so Statewide
facilities we have a number of
underground fuel tanks for diesel and
for and for gasoline to fuel our Fleet
we have worked very hard to stay in
compliance with the with the current
regulations
and we've done some
uh not only Replacements but a lot of
fuel top
um
improvements to stay in compliance with
the regulations and this level of
funding and this this type of capital
budget request would allow us to
continue to
um
keep working on those fuels fuel sites
and and keep in compliance
um I'm not saying that without this we
would we would jeopardize compliance I
don't think it's it's that
um I I don't think it's it's that close
but but but down the road uh that is a
concern that we need to keep up on
maintaining these and keep them in
compliance
and the third item is a uh a third
priority is an item to look at
installing some crew Quarters at our
Patrol sheds over the past several years
we have had findings from the State Fire
Marshals office that our Patrol sheds
are not in
uh compliance again with
um standards of of Life Safety and and
things like that we have some again very
old facilities
um they are much more
um active uh garage type of things
um historically we had to have
um lounge chairs or bunks or things like
that
um
uh and the Fire Marshal's office and and
the review of their our facilities have
have
ding dust so to speak that we aren't in
compliance that if we are going to have
people sleeping there for extended
periods of time and periodically during
some of the winter storms we will have
people
staying at the shed and trying to get
rest breaks for
um extended periods of time that they
need to have two means of access they
can't be you know sleeping in the in the
mezzanine or The Lofts or they we can't
have them sleeping you know in the
garage area and things like that so this
funding request is a um is an attempt to
address those findings from the fire
marshal uh and and make our sheds as
compliant as as possible with with with
the with those findings
and there's more information and and
further in the packet that we can get
into but uh and again at a high level
that's what the that's what they ask and
that the request is
so
um those are our three highest priority
uh
um items that we again not funded in the
governor's budget but that we would ask
consideration of the other thing that I
would point out is that because we had
made that request for those three
highest priority uh ones our budget
submission and The Debt Service in in
estimation in our budget does already
account for these for these three top
priorities so The Debt Service
estimation that we've done and put in
our budget uh was done in consideration
that this
request was was going to be was going to
be funded in hb2 so The Debt Service
should be addressed uh and taken care of
for these top three so I'll pause there
because I see a question so we can go
into some further needs representative
Jack uh thank you Mr chairman again
um knowing that we could fund the nine
or the 23 million dollars
and the net effect of it would be to
reduce the amount that we have next year
to apply to Highway projects uh do you
have a priority of doing these projects
versus whatever effect it would have on
the on the 10-year plan uh programming
um
one of the one of the one of the
clarifications I I'd like to make is
this probably doesn't really affect the
10-year plan Highway doesn't affect the
10-year plan funding most of the um
tenure plan funding is federally funds
you know from past discussions we don't
match the federal funds with State funds
the impact of of this uh would be on our
operational budget our operations budget
and and and and the net underlying
health and surplus of of the highway
fund so it wouldn't uh it wouldn't
affect the capital it wouldn't affect
the highway program or the number of
projects or the projects that we would
do in the 10-year plan but it is a
balance as we look at these needs and
and like I said the underlying
operational
needs and funding in our operational
budget and the underlying health and
balance in the highway fund
thank you yes representative Melbourne
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question my question is in
reference to the fuel tanks when you
pull the the other fuel tanks that are
in there now I imagine they're
supposedly steel tanks correct
I believe so some of them are the older
ones are yes yeah uh are you going to
replace them with fiberglass tanks
and what are you going to do if you find
out that one's leaking
any of the projects that we've done
um you know any of the replacement
ending the fuel tank Replacements that
we do are in compliance and and and with
the with the current standards so
um I believe that fiberglass Dave
Rodriguez assistant commissioner can
help me but um you can have some more
detail I believe the fiberglass but I
know they're they're double walled and
and and and everything up to the current
standards
um and if there is any any fuel tank
storage we would have as part of the
contract a uh soil or fuel remediation
aspect of the contract
um typically through our investigations
before doing a project we would have
identified a a problem or or or a leak
or something like that and it probably
would have been a higher priority than
than this than this type of capital
budget request we probably would have
been trying to address it on an
emergency basis but but with that said
um I know we would um in all of our
contracts that involve underground
storage tanks we do have a um a
contingency plan for either contaminated
soil or or fuel remediation if it is
encountered during the work and Dave
I'll let you correct me if there was
anything very good okay if if I could uh
did you have a follow-up to that
representative yes I was going to just
ask him one more question when you if
you do do this are you going to put the
tanks back in the ground are you going
to put them above ground
want to take that one I've called Dave
up so I wanted to have the opportunity
yeah good afternoon my for the record my
name's David rodrigue assistant
Commissioner of of dot all of our
current tanks are underground tanks and
our replacement tanks go underground as
well
thank you thank you
um
and um I I've probably heard this answer
before but can you tell me why we're not
using the odd fund for these
Replacements remind me why
the state's buying fuel right well I
believe I mean we tie into the odd fund
to the dude to the degree that we can
but um I don't think that the odd fund
reimbursements that that would be
available uh meet the need for the for
the replacement but we do tap into the
odd fund to the degree that that we're
able to
I'm I'm happy to be corrected but if the
if the Department's been under
compliance and it is and has done their
reports and so forth and the state I
will speak from a station owner that
went through this and many of my friends
have yeah
um you know the the liability is only in
the matter of tens of thousands of
dollars when the remediation can be a
million dollars so
so I could you just explain that a
little further do you know Dave yeah
I'm not sure that I fully understand the
question what what I can say is we have
made use of the odd funds in the past
we've also made use of the lust funds
which are leaking underground storage
tank funds in the past currently all of
our sites are in compliance and we we
have a proactive plan to keep them in
compliance and part of that proactive
plan is to upgrade them regularly into
change of Tanks be before they're
leaking while all of our tanks are in
compliance in all of our piping is
doubled walled in compliance as well
you'll see from some of the pictures in
the report
um our concrete pads don't all have
positive limiting barriers and and so
forth many of our pumps are old and many
of our tanks are well beyond
um their warranty period
um and from our perspective the
replacement of these sites and we also
use this fund for tank top upgrades as
the commissioner had explained to work
to stay ahead of it so that we don't get
get behind in our 96 plus or minus fuel
site locations okay thank you
the if if I could how where are we on
the list of salt sheds we have 100 plus
we keep funding for year after year
after year that I've been here are we
halfway or where are we
ballpark all right
uh again that would be an an estimation
but we are still replacing many salt
sheds that were built in the 70s as pole
barns with old utility poles and
um Hemlock slabs that we would often
mill ourselves back in those days as as
we built them and viewed my estimation
is fewer than half of our 100 or so on
locations have modern salt sheds most of
them still are the the older pole sheds
and also the way these programs are put
forward unfortunately again if we have a
hundred plus locations and each one
lasts 50 years you always got to replace
two a year so this will likely keep
coming back from us successors for years
to come thank you for that
further question representation okay yes
uh commissioner Cass and welcome back
and congratulations on becoming
commissioner thank you uh the reason I'm
your first two priorities for Highway
funds the construction of the salt and
sand sheds at just over 2 million and
the second one underground fuel tank at
2 million in this book but I noticed in
this Blue Book the capital Improvement
they list it for uh 2.5 million for both
those items I'm wondering which estimate
is more accurate if you've seen the the
uh estimates in the Blue Book
I apologize I would have to look I would
have to look okay because I noticed this
discrepancy and I don't I don't know
obviously I think you are the past years
rather be doing your figures but I just
want to be aware of a higher figure for
those two items in the blue book here I
I apologize if I didn't do my homework
and and dig into that uh historically in
the past
um as we've done our estimates and
internally and they get vetted through
dis and and they look at them
um you know they have some standards in
terms of per square footage and other
things and and their administrative
costs I would ha I would I would
I would guess based on on their
expertise well we we have the expertise
in the salt sheds and our experience
with with with with these but typically
you know the building and the capital
projects are reviewed by Das and I would
know and I would typically defer
to the estimates that they had done
thinking that they have more of the
expertise and would be more current but
I can verify you know again those but
okay
yes representative I'll come back to
Eaton thank you Mr chairman uh two
questions uh the first one is it uh
which is a better value but the the
storage tanks back in the ground or
putting them above ground because I
noticed that you indicated there were no
safety sidewalls for leakage and stuff
like that on your concrete pads that are
in the ground so uh
are they being upgraded in the second
part of that question uh I have is own
the salts sheds when y'all rebuild these
salt sheds do y'all put a membrane or
something down that captures any of the
salt that may migrate into the ground
itself and thank you sir thank you yes
thank you for your questions our current
fuel sites are all underground and will
continue to to be all underground and
that's most Costa effective for us they
they are dual wall tanks a modern tank
is is double walled and tested and has
sensors inside so that we can notice the
leaking we've done cost benefit analyzes
to go above ground and for for us the
best cost benefit is to go underground
and with respect to the the salt sheds
they they all do have Linings they're
all paved inside they also have
collection systems sometimes when the
salt's delivered it's wet some of that
water even though it's undercover will
reach out and we'll collect that water
and tanks to prevent protect the
environment
you're welcome
representative Eaton
so in an area that you haven't tapped
yet but um possible about a dozen years
ago you guys were looking at an RFID
system for Fleet Maintenance tracking uh
for better management of
snow any kind of Maintenance you folks
do and to avoid pilfridge uh in fuels
you're going to have RFID for the tanks
for the vehicles and personnel and due
to a member no longer here who was a
privacy fanatic and always saw an
ulterior motive it got trashed on the
floor that member is farming and wear so
any
thoughts of looking at that because my
recollection is that it wasn't a
horrifically expensive program but had a
fast turnaround in Payback
you speak to that I'm not sure yeah so
as I recalled there were two different
items that that the RFD RFID tags were
were talked about for when it comes to
our fuel distribution system and for
fuel that the dot uses all other state
agencies use many municipalities and and
so forth we do have a a very modern
system we replaced it in the last
capital budget and we'll talk about that
for the lap State extensions next week
we have a very modern system that does
have fobs that every driver has to do
have
um we also have passwords and key in and
we track that very closely by vehicle
and then for the dot ourselves sometimes
we have to put fuel in a can for a
lawnmower we track that very very
closely and for for all of our equipment
there are in the current software
there's different thresholds so if you
think takes 20 gallons you can't pump
30. we're on it thank you thank you
yes representative Newman
thank you
I'm I'm looking at some of these
pictures and and back to the Salt sheds
that there's quite a difference between
on page 33
but this this one's driving me nuts I'm
45 the bottom picture
um
apparently it's in Franklin and it's
the combination of salt and sand it's
currently inefficient
is is that because there's not a
separation between the sand and the salt
because it looks a lot better than the
stuff on page 33.
I think
45 yeah no I think you're exactly
exactly right that that gambrel style of
salt shed that you see there in Franklin
on on 45 is um is um is an example of a
more modern
salt shed that we would want so the item
that that is a little bit further down
on the line that this is referred to is
is some cold storage
um additions so right now you see this
this uh in in that picture there's some
there are some there are some concrete
blocks and stuff there separating the
salt pile from the sand pile and some
other gravel and tar and stuff in front
there so that that item would be uh you
know to uh some capital budget items and
it's further down in our priority list
to build some uh some some cold storage
so that we could
um
you know keep that other sand and gravel
and stuff
you know in a separate Place undercover
and be able to fully utilize that that
salt shed right now that salt shed isn't
being fully utilized
um
because of that that kind of cold
storage use that's put in there as well
too okay just to find so I under
mine
the side it doesn't have dividers
appropriate right for the materials what
what what what what we would desire and
that that project would be whether it's
a lean-to to this or or some separate uh
shed type of building to
construct some cold storage to to store
that material in undercover and and be
able to fully utilize the uh the salt
shed this is being used as a
stop Gap measure because because because
they don't have the ability to store
some of that material undercover thank
you but yes I mean you compare that that
type of uh is that a gambrel my Arch
gambrel salt shed to the to the pole
barn ones that that Dave had referenced
which are pictured on 31 page 31 32
and there's a remarkable difference and
you can see some of the the the decay in
deterioration of the of the polls
starting and that's some of the reasons
that we want to keep up with a routine
replacement of these older facilities
thank you further questions we're
running a little long here
commissioner what else would you like to
speak on
um well depending on the on the um
committee's uh favorite so I've
identified the top three priorities I
mean we have other priorities I
identified there some roof Replacements
uh new satellite garage and a couple of
Patrol sheds historically historically
we have
uh if you look at our capital budget
from past years we've always tried to do
you know again similar to the Salt sheds
we have a hundred or so Patrol Patrol
sheds around the building we've
typically always tried to do you know uh
some some salt sheds and one Patrol shed
at least per biennium in this biennium
our priority is the is the is the is the
crew coordinates in the in the in the
retrofit of some of our Patrol sheds to
meet those light safety
um issues that were identified by the
fire marshal but further down on this
list there are a a number of um
there are a number of priorities that um
that we've identified
um
uh we are continuing and on priority
number four we're continuing uh to build
a work order system uh phase three we
are
currently finishing phase one and moving
into phase two phase three is is at the
end for the implementation
um which which would which would
would help complete that work order
System project again representative
Newman had noted uh under item number
five some of the cold storage editions
we talked about those
um Twin Mountain
that's the maintenance facility that's
the um
that is the that is a remote
um
uh Mechanical Services uh garage and and
Twin Mountain that uh you know has a has
a an old
um steel roof that needs to be replaced
so those are identified needs that that
we need to get to and I'm taking us down
to ideally
um uh priority number eight which would
be uh Lancaster and a new satellite
garage there so these are all needs that
we've identified we would like to get
down to i d in an Ideal World we would
get down to replacement of a couple of
the patrol sheds there
um and and represent answer to
representative Jack's question it is it
is it is a balance we did run some
numbers and to fund
down to about the length about priority
number eight uh the Lancaster uh
satellite garage would
equate to about a million dollars of of
Debt Service
um like I said The Debt Service
from the first three priorities are
already
um
taken into account in our budget
presentation
uh in our in our budget not our budget
presentation but in a in our budget
um you know getting down to say the
Lancaster uh satellite garage priority
number eight
um would add about uh a million dollars
in debt service in the future years
um
which would which would go against the
highway fund so these are needs
um uh I guess I'd ask for the
consideration I'm not uh I you you all
know what other agency requests and
stuff are
um my senses
from the
um
you know the current state of things uh
if uh funding the top three priorities
and
um maybe the next two or three was under
consideration we would consider that
pretty pretty successful and set us up
um for the next couple of years
all right and be manageable and probably
be be manageable from a Debt Service and
impact of a highway fund and be a little
more incremental than the full million
dollars of debt service that I had
mentioned
all right have you uh had conversations
with the treasurer about that
um treasure be involved on Highway funds
we have not haven't
the treasurer would be involved uh in in
our budget presentation with the debt
service for the um for the top three
priorities that is and I believe has
been vetted through the treasure
um the treasurer would be involved but I
don't believe those discussions
um I only bring that up because you said
it's only another million dollars right
that's I'd like to hear some and I'm
making no promises here sure yeah but I
I think that would be if you could get
that conversation handled and get back
to me I'd appreciate it understood right
okay and I didn't mean to imply to only
a million dollars I I I I I hesitate to
bring that it's a question that I asked
as we were looking at these needs you
know what is the financial impact from a
Debt Service of that I fully appreciate
it I didn't mean it to be I I'd figured
it'd be like a conversation I had with
my wife that it's only another
no I I fully appreciate that is is there
is there anything else at this point
you'd like to bring before us
um anything on your own Lines no no I
appreciate the committee's uh
consideration and and and reviewing
these I know even the top three
priorities that weren't um included in
the governor's budget uh I do appreciate
the committee's consideration of those
requests thank you and could I just uh a
sidebar item
um I had a I was at a meeting with a
presentation from uh University of Maine
Orono and they are doing I appears to me
it's probably you know old technology to
you but 3D rendering of uh iron
poly girders for Bridges and I
understand that they're going to start
trying that in Maine
and it just seemed to me two things
wouldn't it be nice if the university
system was working cooperatively even
more with your department and
you know is is that something that's
even being thought of by the department
I don't want you to spend a lot of time
short answer is yes the uh the UMaine
Orono has a has a regional
um kind of uh Transportation that's not
a transportation center but a
transportation research area there um
when it opened a few years ago we were
in attendance and we uh you know
regularly participate in some of those
uh and some of those efforts um we have
close relationships with our um
counterparts in in Maine and I know
exactly what you're talking about uh we
have
um
seen those at various
conferences and presentations the uh the
the the the company that that is
involved with doing doing those
um had also been involved with some
other
um other Innovative type of bridge
bridge building techniques I don't know
if you've ever heard of bridge in a
backpack was one of their ones with some
poly poly-filled um some concrete filled
uh
tubes and things like that so short
answer is uh yes we are involved in
looking at those and
um
hopefully we can take advantage of of
those I know there was one proposal for
a bridge of municipals a municipal uh
one of the state aid Bridge projects in
Lebanon
um that the consultant had come and
approached us if we would uh
if we would entertain that that that
idea for that uh for that project and we
said certainly it would be a good
project to see so it is on the horizon
on the state-owned structures we tend to
be
more conservative and and look for more
tried and tested technology but um
hopefully that's not too long of an
answer no that's fine thank you
all right thank you all for your
attendance
yes
uh we will
um if if members need to get up and walk
and come back that's fine but I we have
held up police standards for some time
here and
I'm sure you're anxious to get back so
when you have a chance sir please come
forward
yes
why don't we go ahead and open up our
next presentation
police standards and please just come
forward and
welcome to Public Works and
um tell us about your proposal
uh thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
committee members for this opportunity
uh for the record my name is John skip
I'm the director of New Hampshire police
standards and training
and the mission of our organization is
to shape sustain and strengthen the
competency and professionalism of New
Hampshire law enforcement and that's in
service to our state
we're an independent executive branch
agency governed by 17-member police
standards and training Council we're not
affiliated with any law enforcement or
prosecutorial agency and thereby
avoiding potential conflict of interest
with our regulatory function and
decertification duties
we set the hiring and educational
standards for all police state
corrections and probation parole
officers in the state of New Hampshire
we operate the New Hampshire Police
Academy that every full-time
Municipal County and state law
enforcement professional must attend to
become certified as a full-time police
officer in the state
we also operate the part-time Police
Academy that all part-time officers must
complete to obtain their certification
as well as the New Hampshire Corrections
Academy that all State Corrections
Officers attend to obtain their
corrections officer certification
we oversee the law enforcement conduct
Review Committee
this committee receives allegations of
police misconduct they oversee the
investigations into such matters and
then review the results of such
investigations to validate the findings
and present those findings to the
council for their consideration
created by executive order and
administratively attached to our agency
is the law enforcement accreditation
Commission
which is a body that has created a
voluntary accreditation program to
advance law enforcement professionalism
through the establishment of
Professional Standards and the
administration of a formal mechanism by
which New Hampshire police agencies can
be systematically measured evaluated and
updated
we also provide a catalog of specialized
advance and in-service refresher
training
at our facility here in Concord and
regionally around the state to assist
all officers in completing the annual
requirements to maintain their
certification
the council holds disciplinary hearings
and may suspend or revoke the
certification of officers that have
violated Council rules or committed a
crime or act of moral turpitude
we provide services with uh
this number has changed it's uh 22
full-time positions and five part-time
positions which include sworn staff
clerical staff and building maintenance
employees
our staff is assisted by adjunct
instructors most of whom are unpaid
volunteers and a small number of
contracted instructors
we operate a 77 000 square foot training
facility located on 20.87 Acres of
grounds across from nhti
our present conditions are that we are
in desperate need of more classroom and
Office Space
and to provide background the following
is offered our current facility was
constructed in three phases
for the sake of brevity I would ask that
my written testimony with regard to the
three phases be entered into the record
but I won't read it
thank you
with regards to our budget request we're
in desperate need of the classroom and
office space so that we can more
efficiently provide training to New
Hampshire law enforcement
it should be noted that several
increases to our agency's training and
standards Mission have been added over
the last two years to include the
increase of mandatory in-service
training for every officer annually from
eight hours moving to 24 hours annually
a major increase in Crisis Intervention
training with an initiative to have at
least one officer from every Police
Department BCIT trained
we've taken over the active shooter
response training from New Hampshire
Homeland Security and Emergency
Management
and as I've read earlier we have also uh
the new task of running the conduct
Review Committee as well as the
voluntary law enforcement accreditation
program
we make the following two Capital
Improvement project requests and one
lapse extension request
project number one
we are requesting a total of three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars from
the general fund to move the virtra to
an existing outdoor building
and reclaim classrooms three and four
this project will call for building
upgrades to the existing elk building to
house the virtra moving the virtra to
the new location and then reconfiguring
classrooms three and four back to their
original state
if this project is approved it will
provide us with two classrooms to hold
in service classes uses an academy
breakout room and provide room for
scenario training
project number two we are requesting one
hundred and fifty thousand dollars from
the general fund to convert the existing
break room into a classroom
this project will also allow us to add
an additional office
to house the extra staff that we've just
hired
if this project is approved it will
provide us with an additional classroom
to hold in-service classes uses an
academy breakout room
and room for scenario training
and finally we request a lap extension
for the appropriation made to the police
stands and training Council in 2019
cited under that site number for the
boiler replacement the boiler
replacement was nearly completed when
during the final phase of the
construction project the engineers
discovered that a hot water tank and
piping would need to be replaced in hot
water high temperature issues with
recruit showers would need to be
addressed for safety Public Works
initiated DPW project number
8117c domestic Hot Water Systems
upgrades
now Public Works has advised us that
they cannot get this job completed prior
to the end of this biennium
and request that we ask for the funds to
be available for the next biennium
therefore we respectfully request that
this project be removed from the labs
list and extended
we are requesting the two Capital
Improvement projects to address our need
for more classroom spaces that we can
adequately address and present the
future training needs and mandates for
the New Hampshire for all of New
Hampshire law enforcement
it is our position that these two
Capital requests to reconfigure existing
space within the existing dimensions of
our facility is common sense and
fiscally responsible
these two requests will provide for much
needed training space to more
efficiently deliver
up-to-date recruit training to newly
hired law enforcement officers and
provide specialized and in-service
training for our in-service officers
we are requesting the lapse extension so
that we can have the unanticipated work
completed to finalize the boiler
replacement project
I thank you all for listening and I
stand ready to answer any questions that
you might have
thank you all right does it concern the
lives
okay can I before before I move to uh
uh representative uh Jack's question uh
can you please tell me what that Vera
trainer is
uh thank you for the question Mr
chairman uh the Virtua trainer is a
um
a very expensive simulating uh simulator
device that allows the officers to
um
be placed in scenarios where their uh
weapons can be used to respond if they
choose that that's an appropriate
response and that device will allow the
officers to measure whether they made
the right decision and whether they're
the use of their weapons were accurate
sounds good sounds important uh we use
one here yeah we uh so we put it inside
a building yes sir but now we're going
to take it out of the building and we're
going to put it in an outside and make
some adjustments to the outside
so that it can work there also
so uh we presently have two existing uh
garages that are uh Standalone garages
on our property we're going to take one
of those garages and uh finish it off
put heat and power to it and move the
vertra to there okay thank you yes sir
representative Jack uh thank you first
off your lapse extension request is
noted We'll add that to to the lapse
extensions uh secondly the governor's
budget has 300 000 for the uh virtual
move and you ask for 350. so do we need
to give you the extra 50
thank you for the question sir you do
not it that is my um my error 300 is um
what I would be requesting
thank you sir thank you for further
questions
I I
um before I close I do have a question
for you that's not related to this so
perhaps you could leave a card and it's
a request from one of my towns okay
absolutely Mr chairman so if you have
nothing else for us
I believe we've concluded our business
thank you thank you Mr chairman thank
you committee Mr chairman I had a
question
I didn't see it please go ahead
uh are you are you using sorry thank you
for taking my question uh are you using
the attracted trailer truck simulators
we do in my town we had one just
recently down there we uh we do not have
a simulator in a tractor trailer ours is
actually housed inside the building our
simulator
uh it does make uh an interesting day
when we're using the simulator and we
have classes in the lecture hall right
next door it gets a little loud but um
ours is inside the building it's not uh
mobile
thank you sir any further questions
thank you sir thank you
and we have State Police
Department
okay
thank you
commissioner Quinn if you could just
give us two minutes and then we'll start
in
yeah please do
you would be the last person I would say
no to sir
commissioner Quinn welcome to Public
Works and I guess we saved the best for
last year our last presentation so right
on are we on sir you are sir well good
afternoon Mr chair and honorable members
of the House Public Works and highways
committee my name is Robert Quinn
commissioner of the Department of Safety
with me today is Mr Steve Lavoy the
director of administration we're here
today with four projects two that have
been funded in HP 25 one project that
we'll be requesting funding for and the
last which we'll be requesting a lapse
extension Amendment Mr Lavoy will speak
to these individual projects and we're
happy to answer any questions
individually or at the end of the
presentation thank you sir thank you
thank you commissioner it's on the
presentation pack packet that you have
here on page two the first project
that's funded in a house bill 25 is to
replace the state's message platform
it's a 1.3 million dollar request this
is a piece of hardware and software that
passes information between all the
different members of the criminal
justice
system in the state and including
federal state and local entities
so inbound and outbound queries occur
for the national instant criminal
background check system Interstate
identification index National Crime
information center and national sex
offender registry and so Statewide data
including violations and convictions and
judgments are passed between state
agencies as well including Department of
Safety both the DMV and State Police and
then also the Department of Corrections
the court system and local and County
Law Enforcement if you look at page
three page three is a good graphic to
kind of show exactly how this system
works and what we're talking about the
green cloud in the center that's the
message platform switch and it's really
connecting all of these different
systems all of these different databases
and users so that the criminal justice
system can operate effectively in a
modern way without passing paper
the second project that's funded on page
four
are improvements to the state police
helicopter it's 1.5 million dollars
worth of improvements
State Police operates a Bell 407
helicopter that includes a FLIR camera
and mapping software that was last
updated in 2016. and that system is
approaching end of life and needs to be
updated and upgraded to continue to
operate safely the service is utilized
by the helicopter include search and
rescue support for SWOT calls crime
scene reconstruction photography and
then also support for major disaster
scenes and storm damage assessments
and so these improvements would update
the camera itself also update the
mapping Mission computer that's used
during flights and we'd also have some
updated flight equipment for the pilots
including and the flight and the
Troopers who go along on the flights
that's white phosphorus night vision
goggles helmets with counterbalance for
those goggles noise cancel oh I'm sorry
noise canceling headsets and then flight
suits jackets gloves and boots
on page five there are some photographs
of the existing uh helicopter uh the
cabins on the top left the cockpits
being shown on the bottom left and then
the mission computer which is used by
the fto the flight terminal operator is
shown on the right and that's what
really combines the images from the
camera so that action can be taken
decisions can be made
those are the two projects that are
currently included in house bill 25. we
do have one additional request which is
not included and that's an update to the
DMV document scanning system
currently the DMV utilizes microfilm to
Archive documents
the reality is is that microfilm is
quickly becoming obsolete the equipment
that we have is failing and is regularly
it's challenging to maintain at this
point and find parts to keep it running
most recently it's been a challenge to
find a vendors who are able to develop
microfilm we had an RFP that actually
just went out and came back with zero
responses so this is something that's
critical at this point that needs to be
addressed we're seeking a million
dollars to implement an a digital
scanning solution that would include
indexing of documents to align with the
existing driving Vision driver licensing
and registration systems and ensure that
we can align those documents to the
drivers and and the vehicles that they
belong to
page seven shows some photographs of the
current equipment that are being used to
scan these documents on the top left
that's the microfilm image capture
machine you can see the pages get pulled
through and photographed through that
unit Circa 1993-94
bottom left is a developed microfilm
spool which is read by the reader on the
top right
uh and then just an example of the the
microfilm that's ready to be read that
was developed on the bottom right
page eight is a summary of the request
that we just spoke about to projects
funded in House Bill 25 for a total of
2.8 million dollars and then the
additional request that we're asking the
committee to consider today which is
another million dollars for the DMV
document scanning updates
and then lastly on page nine
we do have a lapse extension request
related to the state police Hangar so
this was a project that was funded as a
joint project with military Affairs and
Veterans Services
um
it was a combination of federal and
general funds many of the members on
this committee Might Recall we had
challenges in building that and finding
fire suppression that would be suitable
on the federal side which caused delays
on our state side the state doesn't have
to follow Federal DOD regulations for
fire suppression which caused delays in
the project so this committee with
representative Graham's assistance
helped us to reallocate those funds to
State Police so we could move forward
with the new
Hangar project unfortunately prices have
increased since that time and we're now
in a position that the new Hangar
project would be approximately four
million dollars to complete so the 2.4
million that we have is not sufficient
we've done some work we've working with
public works and determined that we can
renovate the existing Hangar with the
Appropriations that we have but in order
to do so we would need to have the lapse
extension language change to include
renovation as an option and so that's
what we'd request the committee to do to
authorize the change that it's listed
here to add renovation to the language
in the labs extensions
thank you Mr chairman I'm sure Mr Shea
will correct me if I'm wrong you have to
actually go back and amend the original
appropriation to the new language and
then extend it through the years that it
was extended it's not sufficient just to
change it in this year's HP 25.
if so that's what we'll do then that
would be the request that we would make
okay so that's what we'll do uh you have
three other
uh extensions those are all valid and
there's nothing there's nothing else
that needs to be changed uh correct
those are all valid as is they're all
necessary to complete the projects and
uh We've we have submitted
um a response to the subcommittee uh
with additional details related to each
of those
thank you represent Mills thank you Mr
chair um correct me if I'm wrong I'm
maybe uh because I remember going
through all this about the hangar
because I co-sponsored a bill with
representative Graham wasn't this
supposed to be a joint hanger between
you and the military isn't there
military money involved in this there
was originally and because of the
challenges that we face with the fire
suppression systems
um the action that was taken during the
last session was to split the funding so
the state funding came to State Police
and the federal funding stayed with um
with Veterans Affairs so
so I guess what I'm hearing is that
you're going to renovate your old Hangar
and we can still expect the military to
come back looking for their new
helicopter hanger you're gonna we won't
you won't know that
without a question would you believe
would you believe
thank you further questions yes
representative Jack uh thank you and one
other question on
page six uh you have the source of funds
for the million as 100 cost of
collections I don't quite understand
uh if that's in other funds or a general
funds to be reimbursed or what the
source of funds for this actually is
sure so that's that's another funds
category
um it's actually Highway funds before
those revenues are deposited into the
highway fund
all right
so if I could so if if that if this if
we were to include that one million
dollars then the one million dollars is
going to come out of the highway fund
and is that what you're saying and then
proceeds or Pro monies as you collect
them what will go against that
so the the the payments any Debt Service
as a result of this would be essentially
from Highway fund revenues
but the State Constitution Article 6A
and then also rsa99 requires us to cover
any costs associated with those
collections before those monies get
deposited and so that's what this would
be paid for it's it's DMV Appropriations
are considered Costa collections even
though they're derived from that same
source of funds that same Revenue
collection that ends up in the highway
fund okay
any other questions
yes representative I'll come back just
one quick one that affects everybody in
here for regular ongoing questions on
the 1.349 million
um
does the new switch replacement
expedite or assist in any way the
background checks that we hear about
constantly from all the various sources
of taking so long to get done will it
expedite the process at all
I would like to say yes but I I know I
think what I think I think what you hear
is you know the check is a check the
automation this this is the system I
think what you hear with delays is more
the entire process of the background
checks but um
this this in and of itself this the
checks that are being run today are the
checks that are being run
with this new equipment
thank you it is still the same transfer
receipt of information
thank you representative Newman
thank you
but do just following up on it so how is
is the
it is the is the data that is going into
the system for example the background
check system is it manually input
so so
excuse me
So when you say a background check so if
you're asking if somebody's running a
criminal history check yeah no matter
what it is it is all being you know it's
in like if you look at this information
that's in criminal history or
information that's in the triple I all
the federal indexes when they are
putting in a name and date of birth they
will get those checks run automatically
so that is how that is a query how a
check is being done against a database
when you're asking for the background
checks whether it's for employment or
there are different layers in that part
of a background check might be to run
the criminal history the other might be
other requirements of the employers so
it is it is all if you look at all the
Partnerships and the you know and
everything yeah all of the exchange of
information if you look at all the state
agencies and the courts and Corrections
and so it's it's part of it but but
you're asking about a background check
so I to I think I would have to know
what type of check are you asking for
okay let me let me try it again
I don't know where I read it but there
was concern somewhere and and something
that and I believe it had to do with the
NCIS information that information was
available but it for whatever reason it
just wasn't getting inputted into the
systems for background checks for
example so I don't know if that's
something that you're taking care of so
all this information I certainly support
updating so it can get put in I just
want to know if it's people putting it
in
do you have people to input data or oh
yes well a lot of it's electronic like
the information's transferred a
conviction would be transferred from the
court to the criminal history and
imported electronically so this this
really is uh the foundation of the
entire you know system so when you say
this is the switch the state message
platform for the exchange of information
but
but if you're at like for convictions
the majority of this and that's the goal
with this is to get it all put in
electronically
so from a conviction into the system
into the our criminal history and then
upload it to the federal authorities so
yeah all right thank you
representative Eaton then back just so
it's follow-ups you know where I was
going well we get on an ongoing basis is
from counties and for municipalities of
the length of time it takes and how it
puts constraints on the localities for
background checks for nurses teachers
that sort of thing and
for being luck of the draw
no matter who says what about anything
you get the blame right so I I will just
say this I can speak for um for the team
that are involved in our portion our
requirement of this process and the
process is different depending on you
know where the request comes from they
are doing everything they can to
expedite this and um and put the
resources in place to to get it done as
as soon as possible we've done a lot
over the past year at the um the team
over there to to educate and make sure
and we've worked together with the other
state agencies oplc you know we'll work
close with them to ensure that when
someone says this is this is delayed
well where is it what is it so
um but this is critical
um to to all background checks to to
essentially anything in the law
enforcement community
thank you representative I'll come back
this system is it for public use for
background checks or is it just for uh
city and state type background checks
well this well this system if you if you
look at page three you will see you know
who it connects and what information is
inbound and outbound but
um to keep it at 30 000 feet this is
really law enforcement this is the
switch for law enforcement that
exchanges information
represent Kaczynski
thank you um how how big is this um
this hanger anyway and why it seems kind
of expensive to me what would justify
that kind of cost
I think director Lavoy could give you a
history of where it is what it's
comprised and what the plan is to get it
you know up to spec and something that
we can use
um to to support the division of State
Police
so the existing hanger is about
6400 square feet
um we when we originally were looking at
Renovations
um the cost the estimated cost for
renovation was about 1.2 1.3 million and
that was five years ago so with cost
escalations we do believe that this
amount is is needed for that we're
talking a full full-scale renovation we
need new HVAC system we need to entirely
gut the
um the current office space interior
rebuild that we need to install a water
curtain fire suppression system because
it is still an aircraft
Hangar to protect the the individuals
who are working out of that space
and then replace the roof and also if
funding is available
re-side the the ability and we also do
need to replace the hanger door which is
an old model that doesn't necessarily
have all the safety features that modern
hanger doors have and those can't be
retrofitted into these into these doors
so there is there is a lot to the the
project it is a full renovation of the
facility
it also houses the fixed wing and and it
is critical to the New Hampshire State
Police I was I was just curious on the
size of it yes please follow where is
this located
uh this is on uh Airport Road in Concord
it's 91 Airport Road
okay thank you represent vallone
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I guess I'm asking us
about the I.T piece and the cyber
security that involved because it sounds
like those background checks are such
critical information and could be
subject too again we all know those
characters out there who are locking up
systems and with ransomware so
what's your plan how is it integrate
with the rest of the state
well well we everything that's on our
Network Gets overseen By You know doit
the commissioner doit Dennis Goulet and
they work very hard to um to I would say
support our Network and we've had some
significant Investments recently on
cyber security so
um
I would just say that that there's a
team that focuses on that to ensure that
our information is secure thank you
go ahead
did you have a question
representative
uh Mr chairman if we're done with the
discussion of the three items I just I
want to ask about another one okay one I
I'll why don't why don't you go ahead
mine's a simple question go ahead oh
thank you and and thanks for taking my
question
on a list that was put in
um in the book
the uh there was a first item listed was
a DMV vision driver licensing system
re-hosting
and looking at it it says it's other
is
is it somebody far away or someone who
I'm asking is because it's other so is
it uh
is it completely different way of
funding it or you just don't want it
anymore it's listed number one yep so so
that is um
those other funds are the cost of
collections we spoke about earlier and
we are no longer requesting that project
the the cost to
um the original concept was to move the
vision system to a cloud-based solution
to help with long-term I.T costs which
escalate if you're hosting locally but
in order to do so it was significantly
more than our request and more than we
were willing to request and so we found
an alternative solution to maintain that
system over the next biennium so we no
longer need those funds thank you
I have one more question concerns the
helicopter we we own that helicopter we
don't lease that what's what's our
useful life on that before we need to
replace that
I just don't want to be looking next
year or just wondering what what your
thoughts are yeah I I you know I'm not
comfortable giving you an actual time
frame but I can let you know that with
the helicopter with our aircraft we
regularly go through preventative
maintenance there's scheduled engine
rebuilds that occur so you can really
extend the life of any aircraft if
you're maintaining it properly I
wouldn't be comfortable giving an actual
Financial time if you could I fully
understand and it needs to keep whether
it's a plane or a helicopter in the air
is it is it something we expect 20 years
out of from the time we bought it
I will say
I'm going to take a stab at that because
I asked um I asked Jim Siemens who's um
recently been hired and is overseeing
some of the equipment and projects that
the state police he was a helicopter
pilot himself in the Coast Guard and I
said how many years can we get out of
this
um I I don't think it's they they look
at the engine hours you know like Steve
says they build in the main I think
we're good for I don't think we'll be
coming back in the next two years but I
can't
even two to five but I couldn't speak to
20. Okay but I think but but a lot of
that's an estimate but they pay very
close attention to the engine and the
hours and the the infrastructure of it
but I think we're good for the next few
years all right excellent any uh further
questions at this time is there anything
else you'd like to present at this time
no I would just like to thank you for
your time we thank you for being here in
the job you do thank you thank you
so we are we are at the um end of our
presentations
the
uh heading that subcommittee on Monday
Wednesday we have a pretty full agenda
we also are going to try and exec out
the remainder of our bills yes please
and
um Mr Shea has some documents here to
give you
it's going to be important if someone
can't be here on the 20th that we find
out ahead of time
with any luck we are going to call for a
vote on
on our bill at that time
anyone have any questions
yes just to clarify so next Wednesday no
there's no exec on anything
next Wednesday there is okay but it's
it's exacting on the remaining four
bills that we have okay in public works
exactly executing for
hb25 is the is that 20. oh in this one
okay yeah thanks thanks for that
clarification yep
I believe it is it's
Mr chairman I think in the calendar it's
9 A.M for Wednesday to exec for the
executive session on our four remaining
bills and the the only thing is I mean I
guess we've got to take some action on
those bills whether it's passing them
item or retaining them by the 16th the
clerk at one of our meetings was very
insistent that he wants any committee
reports in his office by noon on
Thursday because we're being in session
but that's what he told us the other day
I'm just stressing so I think we've got
to take do some action on that executive
session either between nine and ten or I
think you have a we have the public
hearing or sometime by the end of the
day on Wednesday right representative
Jack yeah the normal deadline for
committee reports being to the committee
assistant is noon on Wednesday the
calendar deadline Thursday gives them
time to process it through the clerk's
office
so you really have to have it in by noon
on Wednesday if you want it to be in
Thursday's calendar
and and we are going to strive to do
that this coming week one of one of our
bills which should be pretty
straightforward is a naming bill and we
were waiting for information I'm not
going to say anything more than that it
looks like the information has come
forward
yeah
so essentially we have three bills
okay
yes representative Newman yes
just to clarify so the
Lynch and representative Jack he's
that's Monday
Wednesday here for us 10 o'clock are we
doing anything on this I think nine
o'clock nine o'clock anything on the
17th for some reason I have the 17th in
here what day of the week is that a
Friday next Friday yeah we're here
you're booked put it on your dance list
okay if I could just say one more thing
the the lapse extension meeting is the
people on the subcommittee should be
here everyone else is welcome to attend
you're a full participant but it's
totally optional
that's Monday
so does everyone understand that you you
don't necessarily have to be here in in
the uh the recording will be running on
that time anyways but Wednesday we need
a committee
and Friday we're going to start to work
and if maybe even sometime Wednesday so
if you
Tuesday I think
the Hardy will be here
what time on the 17th Mr
it's in the calendar oh okay all right
yeah yeah oh yes Mr chairman
I'm looking at
that notice if we've got
um
work
to be 25.
okay we'll check that
and you're pulling those notifications
from the calendar
okay we'll we'll check on that right now
because if it's not noticed we've got to
scramble little yes
the cat the calendar came out today I
mean I've got a card I'm trying to find
it now to see if it's indicate
while while we're looking for that
represent Mills gone for that uh Mr
shade you have some information to share
with us with what you just passed out I
I do I just wanted particularly for the
new members so they understand what I
just handed to them what you have is
what we talk about is the comparison
sheet so as you start to make decisions
I'll start I'll start excuse me I will
start to populate column D so if you
agree for instance on line three that
the courthouse generator should be
funded at 1.156 I would put that number
there and you would see a difference of
zero so this is just this is everything
that's contained in the capital budget
as it was introduced this isn't the new
request that the agencies have brought
to you
I will try to compile some of that
information to make it a little bit
easier for members but I always
encourage you to also look for
yourselves in case I miss something
secondly representative jacket mentioned
that there's the subcommittee on the
lapse extensions and we'll gather
information the results of that
subcommittee will be shared with the
entire committee
so that you will all get to see what we
conclude from that day of uh meeting
with the agencies and looking at their
information
and then
um the third point was and earlier today
Russell McConkey had said that on
Wednesday we're meeting to start doing
some work on House Bill 25 and if
there's any agencies that people feel
need to come back to address any
questions I would ask that you go
through represent McConkey and that he
contact me so I can contact the agencies
so I would assume if I hear nothing that
nobody needs to come back and that's all
I had unless people had questions for me
all right thank you any questions
Mr Shea
I I think we're done thank you
excuse me Mr chairman I'm sorry to
interrupt but according to the today's
House calendar this is for what I'm just
talking about Wednesday okay he they
have it down 10 a.m for the public
hearing on the capital budget and then
10 30 for the executive okay session I I
don't know whether you'd but this is
what is in the calendar so I don't know
if you had to intent I think you had
intended for I don't know 9 A.M we're
fine we're fine we're fine published all
right okay so it's a 10 o'clock start so
if it's snowing that day you get your
tires warmed up good it's extra time
yeah so that's a
so 10 o'clock A.M we're gonna
that should be the public hearing isn't
it 25
yeah it's
I have it right here this is the printed
cop okay you know whatever all right so
thank you thank you for that that's when
you got your March 15th and then Friday
March 17th our session is at 10 A.M full
committee works this is what you know
the calendar says do we have we have
session next week yes we have the
session on Thursday but you you weren't
planning on coming in anyway Thursday so
and we do have one bill our driveway
permit is on the consent calendar for
Thursday by the way
is everyone clear where we are with it
there's no nine o'clock
okay yes
um
if we wanted to pass them out yes please
do please
thank you
and I think Mr chairman we I had to
researchers send out some email but
these are hard copies that
representative uh Edgar is providing us
and this is gives you some background on
the issues involved in complete streets
which is House Bill 511 which you'll be
considering next week thank you
so that that information is
informational only and we're not going
to discuss any part of that because we
are not in executive session did you
have something to add
okay
come on
thank you Mr chairman
foreign